hey everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel in this session we will
discuss docker fill course in this field
course we will learn everything about
docker in detail we will begin this full
course by understanding what exactly
docker is then we will look into the
services and components of docker in
detail next we will see what docker
container is and what are the basic
commands of a docker container then we
will focus on docker swarm and docker
compose after that we will discuss
everything about docker networking then
we will see how to install docker on
ubuntu and windows 10. next we will talk
about 12 crucial docker interview
questions and answers for beginners and
experienced candidates finally we will
conclude this video by discussing the
differences between the two famous tools
which is docker and kubernetes by the
end of this video i can assure you that
all your docker career related queries
would have been answered
for this training with me i have our
experienced docker expert matthew and
akil together we will take you through
the various topics of docker so let's
start with an exciting video on the
configuration management tool before we
begin make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit that bell icon
to never miss an update from simply
learn
there are either of the two tools for
developing new applications
but one in particular stands ahead of
the pack
we are talking of course about the
docker configuration management tool
according to insights dice.com the
demand for software services had bought
the development operations that is that
devops jobs into tech hiring spotlight
the technical skills that the devops
professionals must have are from
linux fundamentals to the devops tools
like the docker
welcome to simply learn's youtube
channel and in this particular video we
will be understanding the concept of
talker in 10 minutes
but before getting started let's have a
look at the objectives for this lesson
in this session you will have a good
understanding of what docker is
architecture of docker major concepts of
docket tool companies using docker and
also run a few docker commands
docker is an open source software
platform used to build design and manage
applications the purpose of introducing
docker was to make apps work faster
with docker every individual can isolate
an application from an environment and
deploy it on another environment using
docker container
now you must be wondering what a docker
container must be
docker container is a very important
component of the docker ecosystem
docker container is an executable
software package that includes all the
dependencies such as frameworks
libraries etc that are required to
execute an application on other
environments
docker facilitates the process of
testing code faster and reduces the time
consuming process between writing and
running a code
docker does all this with the help of
containerization that helps in deploying
and managing applications
in simple terms docker helps a user to
run code almost in every environment
whether you want to run your application
in a local machine or on the cloud
infrastructure docker solves all your
problems with minimal effort
also containers can be moved from one
hose to another without any major
changes
now let us move into our next section
what is docker architecture
docker is a client server app
docker daemon serves your application to
create deploy shutdown etc and the
docker client communicates with the
daemon to manage its services client and
server are found in docker engine docker
engine or docker is a client server
application that builds and executes
containers using docker components
now we know the major components of
docker what are the other components
which are used to build and execute
docker containers well
the other two components you need to
know are the docker image and docker
registry the docker image is a template
of instructions that are used to create
containers image is a read only pattern
that is used to build a container the
image can contain an apache tomcat or
kafka with ubuntu operating system
you can add update and share your images
an image is built using a file called
docker file docker image has multiple
layers whenever a developer builds a
container a new docker layer is
automatically created on top of image
layers and it is called as a container
layer
a docker image provides a separate read
or right layer to each container and
whenever a user makes a change to the
container that gets reflected upon the
specific container layer alone
now moving forward let's understand what
a docker registry is
docker registry is a service to the host
and it distributes docker images amongst
users
a repository is a collection of docker
images
in registry a user can distinguish
between docker images with their tag
names docker has its own cloud-based
registry called docker hub where users
can store and distribute container
images
docker registry has public and private
repositories in registry push and pull
commands are used to interact with
docker images the docker registry has
two basic commands one is the push
command and another is the full command
push command basically stores a docker
image and docker registry whereas the
pull command retrieves an image from the
docker registry in simple terms a docker
registry is a storage and content
delivery service that holds a bunch of
docker images stored in different tagged
versions
a docker workflow is a sequence of
actions on registries images and
containers
it allows a team of developers to create
containers based on a customized image
pulled from a registry and deployed
run them on a host server
moving ahead we have our next question
that is who uses docker
increased running capacity is just one
example of how docker is often preferred
choice over virtual machines
the famous global researcher gartner
predicts by the year 2023 more than 50
of the companies will be adopting docker
containers in production
however a serverless container like
docker will have the revenue from a
small base of
465 million us dollars in 2020 to reach
to
944 million dollars in the year 2024
let's move ahead and see what all
companies are using docker some of the
famous companies that use docker for the
growth of their business are spotify
yelp adb
ebay expedia groupon bbc facebook
linkedin and also other companies like
the new york times oxford university
press paypal
sage shopify uses docker
now let's understand why expedia uses
docker and how does docker bring
benefits to their business
expedia has more than 9 000 docker
containers running in aws ecs service
expedia chose docker to speed up the
building and deploying process of the
application which was possible due to
the various docker components like
docker registry and darker swarm
now let us look into the demo in which
we will be creating a docker file and we
will also be executing a few docker
commands
suppose you have set up your development
environment and the workload should be
like first to create an image and then
dock a file for each component of your
application we need to create containers
and execute the required commands and in
the end test share and deploy a complete
containerized application
in this demo let us focus on step one
and step two
first create a docker file
in case you have some source code and a
docker file then proceed to build your
first docker image
and ensure that the containers which are
launched from those images work
correctly
then let's check if we already have any
docker images
as a result we can see no images are
present here
so let's create a new one
to create a new docker image execute
this command
this downloading process may take a
while
now when you execute the command you can
see a list of docker images on the
screen
now among these two images let's delete
one named simply learn
if you execute
docker rm simply learn which is the
remove command as a result one of your
docker images will be deleted
in case you want to remove ubuntu from
docker image
that can also be done by executing the
docker image rm ubuntu command
moving on to the next one let's see a
few docker container commands
so now before executing container
commands let's first pull jenkins from
the docker hub
now the files are being downloaded from
the hub
so let's wait for this full activity to
get completed
so once the process is done execute the
command docker images
here you can see jenkins is getting
downloaded into your docker system
now let's create a container out of that
so execute the command docker
create jenkins
this will help you create a docker
container
now when you execute docker ps space
hyphen a you can see a container which
is in the created mode
in case you want to start a container
execute the command docker start file
name
here our file name is tender napier
but if you want your container jenkins
to be in the running state type docker
run jenkins
now you can see the process has started
so let's wait for a while
so this is the process of creating a
container let's take a little scenario
of a developer and a tester before you
had the world of docker a developer
would actually build their code and then
they send it to the tester but then the
code wouldn't work on their system the
code doesn't work on the other system
due to the differences in computer
environments so what could be the
solution to this
well you could go ahead and create a
virtual machine to be the same of the
solution in both areas we think docker
is an even better solution so let's kind
of break out what the main big
differences are between docker and
virtual machines as you can see between
the left and the right hand side both
look to be very similar what you'll see
however is that on the docker side what
you'll see as a big difference is that
the guest os for each container has been
eliminated docker is inherently more
lightweight
but provides the same functionality as a
virtual machine so let's step through
some of the pros and cons of a virtual
machine versus docker so first of all a
virtual machine occupies a lot more
memory space on the host machine in
contrast docker occupies significantly
less memory space the boot up time
between both is very different docker
just boots up faster the performance of
the docker environment is actually
better and more consistent than the
virtual machine docker is also very easy
to set up and very easy to scale the
efficiencies therefore are much higher
with a docker environment versus a
virtual machine environment and you'll
find it is easier to port docker across
multiple platforms than a virtual
machine finally the space allocation
between docker and a virtual machine is
significant when you don't have to
include the guest os you're eliminating
a significant amount of space and the
docker environment is just inherently
smaller so after docker as a developer
you can build out your solution and send
it to a tester and as long as we're all
running in the docker environment
everything will work just great so let's
step through what we're going to cover
in this presentation we're going to look
at the devops tools and where docker
fits within that space we'll examine
what docker actually is and how docker
works and then finally we'll step
through the different components of the
docker environment so what is devops
devops is a collaboration between the
development team the operation team
allowing you to continuously deliver
solutions and applications and services
that both delight and improve the
efficiency of your customers if you look
at the venn diagram that we have here on
the left hand side we have development
on the right hand side we have operation
and then there's a crossover in the
middle and that's where the devops team
sits if we look at the areas of
integration between both groups
developers are really interested in
planning code building and testing and
operations want to be able to
efficiently deploy operate a monitor
when you can have both groups
interacting with each other on these
seven key and elements then you can have
the efficiencies of an excellent devops
team so planning and code base we use
tools like jit and geara for building we
use gradle and maven testing we use
selenium the integration between dev and
ops is through tools such as jenkins and
then the deployment operation is done
with tools such as docker and chef
finally nagios is used to monitor the
entire environment so let's step deeper
into what docker actually is so docker
is a tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in a
lightweight container so the application
can work efficiently in different
environments
now it's important to note the container
is actually a software package that
consists of all the dependencies
required to run the application so
multiple containers can run on the same
hardware the containers are maintained
in isolated environments they're highly
productive and they're quick and easy to
configure so let's take an example of
what docker is by using a house that may
be rented for someone using airbnb so in
the house there are three rooms and only
one cupboard and kitchen and the problem
we have is that none of the guests are
really ready to share the cupboard and
kitchen because every individual has a
different preference when it comes to
how the cupboard should be stocked and
how the kitchen should be used this is
very similar to how we run software
applications today
each of the applications could end up
using different frameworks so you may
have a framework such as rails perfect
and flask and you may want to have them
running for different applications for
different situations this is where
docker will help you run the
applications with the suitable
frameworks so let's go back to our
airbnb example so we have three rooms
and a kitchen and cupboard how do we
resolve this issue well we put a kitchen
and cupboard in each room we can do the
same thing for computers docker provides
the suitable frameworks for each
different application and since every
application has a framework with a
suitable version this space can also
then be utilized for putting in software
and applications that are long and since
every application has its own framework
and suitable version the area that we
had previously stored for a framework
can be used for something else now we
can create a new application in this
instance a fourth application that uses
its own resources you know what with
these kinds of abilities to be able to
free up space on the computer it's no
wonder docker is the right choice so
let's take a closer look to how docker
actually works so when we look at docker
and we call something docker we're
actually referring to the base engine
which actually is installed on the host
machine that has all the different
components that run your docker
environment and if we look at the image
on the left hand side of the screen
you'll see that docker has a client
server relationship there's a client
installed on the hardware there is a
client that contains the docker product
and then there is a server which
controls how that docker client is
created the communication that goes back
and forth to be able to share the
knowledge on that docker client
relationship is done through a rest api
and this is fantastic news because that
means that you can actually interface
and program that api so we look here in
the animation we see that the docker
client is constantly communicating back
to the server information about the
infrastructure and it's using this rest
api as that communication channel the
docker server then will check out the
requests and the interaction necessary
for it to be the docker daemon which
runs on the server itself will then
check out the interaction and the
necessary operating system pieces needed
to be able to run the container okay so
that's just an overview of the docker
engine which is probably where you're
going to spend most of your time but
there are some other components that
form the infrastructure for docker let's
dig into those a little bit deeper as
well so what we're going to do now is
break out the four main components that
comprise of the docker environment the
four components are as follows the
docker client and server which we've
already done a deeper dive on docker
images docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the relationship between the
docker client and the docker server and
then we have the rest api in between now
if we start digging into that rest api
particularly the relationship with the
docker daemon on the server we actually
have our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using windows this can be
powershell on mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to run
the docker daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
docker file you'll store that image in
the docker hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what the
container itself looks like is that the
container is a standalone executable
package which includes applications and
their dependencies it's the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that docker image
and to get access to that image we use
the docker registry which is an open
source server-side service for hosting
and distributing the images that you
have defined you can also use docker
itself as its own default registry and
docker hub now something it has to be
very mind though is that for publicly
shared images you may want to have your
own private images in which case you
would do that through your own registry
so once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and i really
encourage you to go out to docker and
see the other docket images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that point
you'll likely want to create a private
repository so you're not sharing that
knowledge with the world in general now
the way in which you connect with the
docker registry is through simple pull
and push commands that you run through
terminal window to be able to get the
latest information so if you want to be
able to build your own container what
you'll start doing is using the pull
commands to actually pull the image from
the docker repository and the command
line for that is fairly simple in
terminal window you would write docker
pull and then you put in the image name
and any tags associated with that image
and use the command pulls so in your
terminal window you would actually use a
simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your docker
environment and that command will be
docker pull with the image name and any
associated tags around that image what
that will then do is pull the image from
the docker repository whether that's a
public repository or a private one now
in reverse if you want to be able to
update the docker image with a new
information you do a push command where
you would take the script that you've
written about the docker container that
you defined and push it to the
repository and as you can imagine the
commands for that are also fairly simple
in terminal window you would write
docker push the image name any
associated tags and then that would then
push that image to the docker repository
again either a public or a private
repository so if we recap the docker
file creates a docker image that's using
the build commands a docker image then
contains all the information necessary
for you to be able to execute the
project using the docker image any user
can run the code in order to create a
docker container and once a docker image
is built it's uploaded to a registry or
to a docker hub where it can be shared
across your entire team and from the
docker hub users can get access to the
docker image and build their own new
containers now let's begin with the demo
we'll be installing docker on an ubuntu
system so this is my system i'll just
open the terminal so the first thing you
can start with is removing any docker
installation that you probably already
have present in your system if you want
to start from scratch so this is the
command to do so sudo apt get remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my
screen okay so before i install docker
let me just ensure that all these
softwares on my system currently is in
its latest state
so sudo apt get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
docker dot io is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we will execute the suros
snap install docker so sudo apt install
docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have
sudo snap install docker so snap install
docker installs a newly created snap
package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker i o
it will take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see docker version
17.12.1
ce has been installed
next thing we do is we pull an image
from the docker hub
so docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a docker image which
is present on the docker hub docker hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
is sudo docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system
and this means that our docker is
working
now we'll try out another command
sudo docker ps minus a
this displays all the containers that
you have pulled so far
so as you can see here there are three
hello world images displayed and all of
them are in exited state so i did this
demo previously too which is why the two
hello worlds which is created two
minutes ago is also displayed here and
the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago is the one we just
did for this demo now as you have
probably noticed that all the hello
world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for docker ps
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running state you can
simply execute sudo docker ps
suro
docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state
and with that we come to an end of our
docker installation docker is something
which is available for most of the
operating systems different different
platforms so it supports both the unix
and the windows platform as such so um
linux through various commands we can do
the installation but in the case of
windows you have to download the exe
file and a particular installer from the
docker hub websites you can simply
google it and you will get a kind of a
link from where you will be able to
download the package so let's go to the
chrome and try to search on for the
windows string
particular installer you will get a link
from docker hub you download it you get
the stable version you get the edge
version whichever version you want you
wish to download you can download it so
let's go back to the chrome so here you
have the docker desktop for windows so
you can go for this table or you can go
for the edge right so you also have the
comparison that what is the difference
between these two versions right
so um the particular edge version is
something which is getting releases
every month and uh the
stable version is getting the releases
every quarter so they are not doing much
of the changes to the stable version as
compared to the edge there so you just
have to double click on the installer
and that will help you to do the
installation of the process so let's get
started so you just click on the get
instable version so when you do that the
particular installer is going to install
now it's going to take like around 300
mb there so that's the kind of installed
which is available so uh once the
installer is downloaded so what you can
do is that you can actually go ahead and
you can uh proceed with the doing the
double click on this installer when you
double click on that you have to proceed
with some of the steps like you know
from the gui itself you are going to
proceed with these steps so we'll wait
for 10 to 20 seconds more and then the
installer will be done and then we can
do the double click and the installation
will proceed
so another thing is that
there is a huge difference between the
installer like for example in case of
unix the installer is a little bit less
but in case of windows it's a gui is
also involved and there are a lot of
binaries which is available there so
that's the reason why you know the huge
size is there now it's available for
free that's for sure and it also
requires the windows 10 professional or
enterprise 64-bit there so um if you are
working on some previous uh version of
operating systems like windows 7 and all
you have the older version called docker
toolbox so they used to call it as like
docker toolbox earlier but now they are
calling it as a docker desktop with the
new docker windows 10 support as such
here so another couple of seconds and
then the installer will be done and then
we will be able to proceed with the
installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads
and here still we have some particular
installations or some download going on
so we'll wait for some time and once the
installation is done then we'll go back
and we'll proceed with installation
so couple of seconds
so it's almost done so i'll just click
on this one you can go to the directory
to the downloads and you can double
click on that also but if you want to do
the installation you can click on this
one also and it will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done so um a desktop a
kind of a gui component will open there
so it will start proceeding with
installation so it's asking whether you
want to add a desktop the shortcut to
desktop so you can say okay i'm going to
click on ok so it will unpack the files
all the files which is required for
docker to successfully install that is
getting unpacked over here so it will
take some time to do the installation
because it's doing a lot of work here so
you can just wait for till the execution
of the installer to be completed and
once the installer is done you can open
your command line and start working on
the docker
so taking some time to extract the files
now it's asking us to you know do the
close and do the restart so once that is
done you will be able to proceed further
and you can just you know run the
command line and any docker command if
you can run so that will give you the
response whether the docker is installed
or not so you can see here that docker
is you know something which is installed
so you can run like docker version you
will be able to get a version of the
client when you do the restart of the
machine then at that moment of time the
docker server will also be started and
then this particular error message will
go off right now the docker daemon is
not up and running because the
installation requires a restart and when
you close on this one and go for the
restart the machine will be restarted
here so this is the way that how exactly
we can go for a docker installation and
we can go on that part now in this one
we are going to talk about the various
components for example what is the
devops here why the devops is important
what is docker the advantages of docker
installation of docker architecture of
docker components of docker game
so these are the different things which
we are going to talk about over here now
let's start with what exactly is in
devops all about here now devops is
nothing but a collaboration between the
development and the operations teams
over here which enables continuous
delivery of the applications and
services to the end user so it's a
combination or collaboration between the
two teams development and operations
which helps us to go for a further
implementation of various processes like
continuous integration continuous
deployment continuous delivery all these
things are possible with this
collaboration over here now why exactly
docker is important for us as such
in a city far away from this one so a
developer decided to develop a tons of
software on a single vm now he can put
up applications he is having a big
server and he wants to host the the
multiple application on a single machine
but for him these virtual machine got a
crash because definitely if you are
putting up more uh different different
applications as such on the on a single
vm
it's not able to take up that much kind
of load over there so in order to avoid
this situation how exactly he can do the
various options or what he can implement
to have this
issue resolved
so ultimately docker is something which
is the solution of him so if he really
wants to host multiple applications
on a single virtual machine or he want
to have different different applications
then docker is the ultimate solution for
him to do that and by doing so
uh there will be no issues as such when
we talk about that the errors or the
uh virtual machines cannot be crashed
and there will be no impact on the
virtual machine as such so why exactly
docker is important so let's talk about
the comparison between the docker and
virtual machine there are very few
reasons why exactly uh the docker is
being chosen open a virtual machine
because virtual machine is a
full-fledged component which can take up
any kind of load but some of the reasons
are still that in which case we will be
preferring the docker instead of the
virtual machine here the very first one
is the memory users so docker is having
a very less memory uses because there is
no concept of guest operating system
whereas on the other hand the virtual
machines are going to take a huge amount
of ram uh resources in order to keep
that particular operating system up and
running second one performance because
uh if definitely if you have less
utilization and the users is less the
performance will be better but for some
reason if you are taking up more
resources and you will not be able to
deliver that amount of performance as
such over there and then again we have
portability so portability is also quite
easy when we talk about the virtual
machines in case of docker it's quite
portable as compared to the virtual
machine and then the last time is that
the boot up time so virtual machine boot
up time is probably in minutes but uh in
case of docker it's in seconds so if we
summarize it on this one so the memory
utilization the boot up time the
performance everything is better in case
of docker as compared to the virtual
machines
right for a classic example let's say
that what about the memory user 9gb of
memory uh you know is something if you
can see that f1 f2 and f3 is there so
green and red color represents the
occupied memory and the wasted memory
now
there is a particular uh utilization of
let's say that um you know a server
which is available there and uh you know
3 gb of
ram is something which is wasted and 4
gb of ram is something which is being
occupied there so app 2 is using like
2gb and then you can see that the
specific 2gb of ram is occupied and 3gb
is occupied and the wasted one is 1gb so
vm can see over there that you know 9gb
of ram is used and the remaining 6 gb of
uh unused ram cannot be reused because
if for example i allocate like 4 gb of
ram to the virtual machine it's there
itself it it gets locked on so
it's not like okay uh i'm using only 4gb
ram out of this
9 gb of ram then the next
5 gb of ram will be totally wasted so
you cannot reuse it for any purpose
so this is a problem with the virtual
machine that if you allocate some memory
to the uh specific virtual machine
if you are not using that much uh
resources or that much memory the
remaining memory will be simply wasted
because this is hardcorely allocated to
a virtual machine and you cannot utilize
these unused memory as such over there
so this is the limitation from the
memory perspective but in case of docker
definitely if you know out of the 9gb of
ram if we are using uh only 3gb of ram
so whatever the unused memory is there
so we can actually use it to for the new
containers so it's not dedicatedly
allocated to the virtual machines if you
are using uh
out of 9gb if you are using 1gb 2gb 3gb
or 4gb whatever the remaining memory is
available that you can simply use it for
the other containers also this ensures
that you always go for an optimal
utilization of your resources and
unnecessarily there is no wastage of the
different different resources or the
different components over here in this
one so that's the reason why the docker
containers are quite uh efficient in
terms of memory when we compare it with
the virtual machine next one is the
performance now um in a virtual machine
we know that you know on the
infrastructure on the physical
infrastructure on top of that you put up
a kind of operating system a base
operating system is there and then on
top of that you have the hypervisor and
this hypervisor then is used to create
the virtual machines which is having a
kind of guest operating system inside it
now the issue over here is that you have
two operating systems over here so the
guest operating system is also going to
take some particular resources and
for example memory or a space
processor so in every terms in every
resource terms it is going to
go ahead and say that okay i'm going to
use the
particular some of the resources now
problem is
that if you're hosting a very small
application you will end up in having a
more consumption because of this guest
operating system will take more more of
the resources and then you are just
using some small very small resources
for your application in an uh real world
so docker container on the other hand
does not have a concept of the guest
operating system and that's where
what happens that the docker engine is
more than sufficient to handle the
docker containers and inside the docker
containers there is the application
which is being hosted over there now
with this one definitely the performance
is quite better as compared to any
virtual machine because of the terms
that there is no unnecessarily wasted of
the resources because in the previous
case virtual machines a full-fledged
guest operating system is up and running
you need some resources to be allocated
to that but in case of containers you
don't need to have that particular
functionality implemented then
portability so um you know having a
portability or moving an application
which works on a system a does not means
that it will work on the system b also
this is a similar problem which we face
that you know the usually the
application works perfectly fine in a
lower environment and when it goes to
the production environment it sometimes
fails and uh it does not comes up
properly so this isn't portability issue
which we have when we talk about the
virtual machines but when in case of
containers when we got a container up
and running in a lower environment and
once the container is prepared you don't
have to do the changes on modification
to that depending on the environment the
same container can be deployed in
production environment and it's very
easy so whatever container prepared in
the lower environment in a dev
environment the same will work in
production environment without any
issues because it contains all the
dependencies and executables everything
inside it so you don't have to do any
kind of modifications or changes to
these containers as such over here and
the last one is a boot up time so uh the
boot up time of the virtual machines is
in minutes and whereas the boot up time
of the
docker containers is in
seconds or probably in milliseconds so
these are the reason why we consider the
virtual machine as an uh resources
based uh environment but on the other
hand docker is something which is quite
light and fast as compared to virtual
machines so let's see that what exactly
is in docker all about here so in this
one you can see uh we have the physical
infrastructure on which we have
the host operating system now we don't
have the hypervisor and the guest
operating system instead of that we have
the docker engine which is taking care
of managing the docker containers and
inside these docker containers you have
the applications and all the required
binaries and the libraries here so there
is no concept of the gift operating
system these docker engine is the uh
person or is the process which is taking
care of all the requests which is going
on and if this docker engine is up and
running then all the containers will
also be accessible and will be available
now docker is nothing but a os level
virtualization
software platform that enables
developers and id administrators to
create deploy and run applications in a
docker container with all its
dependencies so docker is a very
important tool nowadays if you want to
look forward to the host your
application because of its portability
uh benefit that you don't require much
of the changes uh depending on the
platform or depending on the environment
so whatever the developers are able to
build up the same thing will go till the
production environment now let's talk
about what exactly is in doc container
here now docker container is a
lightweight software package
that uh includes all the dependencies
whether it's a base operating system uh
some framework sample libraries it's
it's something which is a part of this
one so that if you will be
if you want to host your application you
will be able to do that so it's a
complete package so both the source code
and the dependencies is what you put up
inside the docker containers now
within these docker containers you can
have multiple applications there
multiple programming languages multiple
frameworks can be hosted there in fact
the databases also can be hosted within
this docker containers you can host them
as such over there now one of the
different advantages of docker let's
talk about that now the first one is the
rapid deployment so rapid deployment is
the very first
advantages which we are getting over
here second
quick and easy configuration
better efficiency
portability
scalability
and security over here now there are
different ways in which we can
understand the
benefits or we can
have the understanding about the docker
here
so uh these are some couple of uh
benefits now let's take up uh take them
one by one the for the first one is the
deployment part so
it's it supports the rapid deployment
now
just like a web application for instance
i want to deploy to website so there are
some couple of steps which needs to be
done across different different
environments like for example if i have
five environments i have to do the
deployment the same steps in all the
five environments at the different
period of time now when we talk about
docker containers we don't have to run
those steps multiple times because once
those steps are executed in one docker
container the same docker container goes
till the production environment so you
don't have to actually do a rebuild of
the docker containers and you can simply
say that okay i have got the docker
container here so you can just run one
or two couple of commands and that will
help you to host your docker containers
so you don't have to redo or rework on
any kind of the deployment work into the
production environment or into the
higher environments and then we goes for
the quick and easy configurations so the
configurations of docker containers is
quite easy you can have your own custom
docker images built out the docker files
so uh these processes can be integrated
within the jenkins also so cicd is quite
possible with the help of docker if you
want to really do that and uh then we
have better efficiency yes they have a
better efficiency and the resources
management as compared to the virtual
machines portability uh we have already
thought about that that it's easy to
move from one environment from one
system to another in fact it's easy from
the developer also so from one machine
from one developer to another developer
it's very easy to move these uh
different docker containers then we have
scalability
scalability is also possible with this
docker containers just like multiple
virtual machines you can also create
multiple containers and you can share
the traffic out of that so but that
scalability and all is possible with the
acquisition tools uh then security is
there so you can have your best
practices of the security implemented
because um it's just a kind of a
virtualization just like a virtual
machine so you have all the uh different
uh possibilities which is available
which you can explore when you talk when
you want to make this stock container
secure right so these were some of the
benefits which was there for the docker
here now let's talk about the
installation of docker here now
installation of docker is pretty common
and uh whatever platform you want
it's available over there so it's
available for ubuntu windows
it's available for mac operating system
so for ubuntu you have to run the
commands on the urban depart operating
system to download it and for windows
it's actually having a
a particular exe file so you can go for
the installation of exe file and then we
have the mac operating system so for mac
operating system you have the dmg files
and when you do the dmg file so it will
uh help you to install the
component over there so mac you can also
use the home view once to do the
installation of that particular
component now next one is the
architecture of docker
now the architecture of docker is pretty
straightforward there are key components
which is available there in the
architecture of docker here the very
first one is the azure client facing is
the docker client now docker client or
you can say that docker cli is available
there now this is the component it's a
command line interface which takes up
the request from the end user like for
example i'm running the command so it
will take all the requests from me as an
end user and it will send those
particular uh things or the requirements
to the docker daemon to the server using
the rest api interface so this docker
daemon is something which keeps on
running on the server and it's a
background process it gets deployed as
an service there in case this docker
demon is not available or it's not up
and running you will not get the proper
response from the docker command line
here so in order to get all your
activity or your
procedures implemented you need to have
the docker server or docker daemon up
and running in fact this docker cli can
be configured to connect to any other
servers or any other different server
docker daemon also so it's a
connectivity which is happening over the
rest api interface where all the
requests are processed are sent to the
docker demon and whatever response is
coming back that is given back to the
end user so what are the different
components of docker here let's talk
about that so docker client consists of
the cli component uh like we have
already discussed so that is something
which is uh going to take up all the
requests from the end user then um it's
using the rest api interface which is
there to have the connectivity with the
docker demon so docker daemon is uh
something which is always up and running
so if you run couple of commands like
docker pull push and also that activity
you are actually sending the request to
the docker demon and docker daemon is
actually doing all the work so it's not
a docker client which is doing it just
taking its kind of interface which will
take the things up and send it back or
send it forward to the docker day
right so it's a background process which
keeps on running on the server on the
operating system and uh it's the same
process across all the infrastructure
all the different platforms whether you
use mac operating system use windows or
you use linux everywhere this is the
basic functionality and it keeps on
listening to the rest api interface so
uh whatever the request new request
comes in it immediately process it and
whatever the response whether you are
stopping a container whether you're
running a container according to that
the action will be taken and the
response will be sent back to the rest
api to the docker client so a docker is
a process or it's a command line which
is used to start the docker daemon
when you run the command like service
docker status on the server you will be
able to see the command which is getting
executed in the back end so there you
can see that docker is the process or is
the command line which is used to
initialize the docker daemon and of
course there is a kind of configurations
which you have to pass it on as a
parameters so even if you run psiphon ef
command you will be able to know that
what process is running from the docker
perspective and the third component is a
particular docker registry so we have a
ready-made uh cloud service which is
available known as the docker hub so you
can actually store the docker images on
these docker registry so there are a lot
of ready-made uh docker images which is
available there but of course you can
have your own uh docker image also over
there or you want you can have your own
custom uh registry docker registries
also for example in jfrog you can have
your private hosted registries also so
all these are different repositories you
can use with your docker container so
docker containers is having the
flexibility that whichever registries or
repositories you want to connect or you
want to establish the connectivity you
can always do that now let's talk about
the docker image over here
in detail
now a docker image is nothing but a
template of instructions
it's having a couple of instructions in
which you will be using these
instructions to create a final dock
container so docker image is uh nothing
but uh for example i want to have a
tomcat apache docker image so what are
the instructions i have to do so the
very first thing is that i have to pick
up a base operating system then on top
of that i will be installing the jdk or
some prerequisite packages and then on
top of that we will be configuring on to
the tomcat apache there so these are the
steps these are the different
instructions step by step procedure
which we are implementing so that at the
end of the uh activity we will be able
to have a docker container ready which
we can deploy to host tomcat apache so
it's a template which is having all the
uh particular instructions in order to
build a docker image you require a file
called dockerfile which is uh of course
having all these different uh
instructions embedded in that so when
you run the dockerfile it acts like a
build tool so whatever the instructions
you are putting up over there all those
instructions are getting uh processed
and you are able to get an end result
then these docker images are actually
comprised of multiple layers so multiple
layers are available there so step by
step so you will be first of all having
a base layer from which the image starts
on top of that another layer for example
you did the installation of jdk so
another layer will be there and then you
did the configuration
of of the tomcat apache and then another
layer will be there so it's a
multi-layered in uh component which is
available and these layers are in
incremental order so definitely the
oldest one will be known as the base
layer and then on top of that all the
latest changes will be done in the
latest layers there so this is an
example now here you can see that
there are four instructions and these
four instructions are also known as the
four layer docker image so whatever the
final docker image you will get in there
you will be able to see four layers of
the docker image here now the very first
is ubuntu so ubuntu 18.04 we are pulling
up and then we are pulling like uh the
file over here and uh then we are
running the make utility and uh once
that is done then we are running that
file dot uh python file over here in
this one so these are four instructions
which is available right so uh which
will definitely help us to do that how
exactly we can make or we can
perform the different activities right
from the base so in this case the base
layer will be like uh the one two one so
one two one will be the base image and
the moment the final cmd attribute or
cmd uh
attributions are processed and executed
after that you will be able to get a
final full-fledged docker image over
there so this will be a full complete
docker image or docker container which
you will get once the whole build
process is completed
now in this case you have uh you can see
that the previous docker file which we
processed so the base layer is ubuntu
18.04 we are not building that actually
it's automatically so it's by default
getting downloaded as in full base layer
after that only we have like layer 1
layer 2 layer 3 added up because those
modifications we are doing it after the
because from does not means that you are
doing any kind of layer modifications it
just like you are importing some base
operating system or base image so
the modification or adding up the layers
is only done after the base layer there
so whenever a user creates a container a
new layer is something which is stopped
on top of the image these layers are
known as the
containers layers so one two one the
very first instruction does not
comprises it is it's not a kind of
container layer we can call it as an
base image layer there so every
container has a separate read write
container layer and any modification in
a container is reflected upon the
container layers only so layer one may
be having some different of uh
instructions layer two may be having
different instructions so like that is a
step-by-step processor
in case
you know whenever our container is
deleted the top layer also gets deleted
over there in that one so if i delete
some particular containers and that is
something which is gone so it was
supposed having like three layers so the
top layer will be simply deleted because
the container is also deleted for that
particular part now docker uses a copy
and write strategy with both docker
images and docker containers so
whenever we uh perform any activity or
whenever copy on uh write strategies and
strategy to share and copy files for
better efficiency so
it's something which is being used to
increase the overall performance of the
docker containers it also makes docker
efficient by reducing the uses of disk
space because whenever uh required okay
whenever is needed only at that moment
of time it's actually performing the
copy
and it definitely reduces the overall
disk utilization and this is very
important also because when you have so
many docker containers up and running so
you have to worry or you have to make
the utilization of a disk or your disk
users or resources also minimum so that
is also you need to make sure that it
does not exceed a particular value
so once the utilization is also less
then definitely the overall performance
will also be better and improved over
here in this case
so uh let's talk about some of the facts
here so the base layers are something
which is purely read-only format so you
cannot do the modifications union file
system saves the memory uh you know by
avoiding the duplications of the files
uh the layers can be combined in a union
file system to create a single image so
all these mail layers are combined and
got a final product or called a you know
you can call it as docker image or
docker containers
and this allows a file system to appear
as a write table uh which is known as
copy on right so copy and write strategy
is being used so to do the changes or to
do the perform the modifications of this
union file system while creating the
different different layers
so
now let's talk about the docker registry
very important component because even if
you prepare the docker image locally and
you don't have the collaborative tool or
you don't have the
tool where you can share these images
definitely it's not easy for you to port
these docker images from one system to
another so docker register is very
important for the portability feature of
docker so docker registry is a service
to host and distribute docker images
among users so uh it can be built up by
one user and multiple users can use it
for example i'm using a jenkins one so
um jenkins uh image is prepared only
once but it's being used by different
people as such docker registry uh again
it's a repository is a collection of
docker images so in a repository you
will be having like different different
uh docker images as such so in registry
a user can distinguish between the
docker images with their tag names so uh
for example jenkins is an a kind of a
single image they might be different
type of images there let's say that okay
let's talk about uh jenkins uh jdk so
there will be image called jenkins the
name of the image will be same but the
tags will be different so one tag would
be like jdk8 one tag would be like jk9
and one time would be jdk 10. so the
difference between all these three
docker images is that that jdk81 is
prepared on jdk8 it's running on jdk8
and if you want to use jdk9 in that case
you have to pull down the the docker
image of jenkins with the jdk 9
installed so depending on the frameworks
or depending on the runtimes so with
these tags different tags are processed
so you can have the distinguished
between the
uh
docker images and whichever docker image
you feel you want to use you can
implement according to your requirement
and docker
by default is having its own uh
cloud-based registry called as docker
hub which gets automatically connected
when the moment you do the docker
installation but in case you are working
into your private infrastructure
so in that case uh you may use the
repositories uh docker repositories on
the uh specific jfrog artifactory or the
private repositories also can be hosted
but docker hub is something which is
having a public and private repositories
both so you can create either the public
and private repositories you can use uh
push and pull activities to interact
with these docker images you want to
download a docker image so you can run
pull if you want to push your docker
image to the docker registry in that
case you can run the push activity so in
both the cases you are doing the
interaction with the
docker hub so when you run some build
process or when you run the containers
there may be some docker containers
which is getting pulled down from the
specific registry from the docker hub
and uh if that specific image and tag is
available definitely pull command will
be successful but in case of push
command you are pushing your custom
docker images uh you cannot push the
ready-made docker images which is
available you can
publish your own docker image only to
the docker hub and then you can further
on do the poll and push activity
accordingly to those repositories so
whatever the ready-made and third-party
images which is available you can only
do the pull activities to them you
cannot do the push activities push
command scenario will only come when you
are looking when you are interacting
with your custom docker image next one
is the docker container now docker
container is an executable package of an
application and its dependencies
together so when we prepare a docker
container we actually combine both the
dependencies and the uh application
source code inside it so the docker
container don't have to look for the
dependencies on the host machine on the
server so this is one of the benefit
where we see that the portability is
very easy because whatever i'm building
up on one system everything is inside
the docker container so i don't really
need to do any further activity on other
machines so whatever works on one system
can be easily worked on in the system
so it's very lightweight also so it can
be easily deployed and executed on you
know on their particular uh servers
because it does not take that much
utilization like a virtual machine so if
you are looking forward for having your
application hosted into your local
system you can easily do it within the
docker container so the utilization is
very less as compared to the virtual
machine so you don't have to worry about
your operating host operating system and
the qualifications
so docker containers can run in totally
isolation just like a virtual machine so
there is no interaction or there is no
interference so they share the os called
uh kernel but uh the thing is they don't
have the interface as such over there so
it works totally in isolation
two different containers will not have
any interaction unless and until we do
we set up that the containers to have
the interactions
now there is uh data volumes where which
can be shared and be used among the
multiple containers so um you have the
capability over here that you know if
the there is some un
used uh space that can be easily shared
across the multiple containers here so
uh it is built using the docker images
so uh using the docker images the docker
containers are built up and docker run
is a specific command which is used to
build a docker container so if you got a
docker image let's say that i have
prepared a docker image a custom docker
image using the docker file now if i
need to create a docker container out of
a docker image i have to run a docker
turn command so docker run command is
nothing
but it initializes or creates an
instance of a docker image now let's
component is the docker compose
now typically when we work with the the
docker containers so we have to run like
if i want to run like five six
containers i have to initialize like
five six times or i have to run docker
and commands five six times there so um
and if you want to create a relationship
between the containers then definitely
that is something which you need to
manage using the docker commands but
sometimes it's not an easy task for you
to run those commands manually or
remember those commands so docker
compose is a utility over here using
which you can actually run multiple
containers with a single service
you just got off
a kind of a single file you just run it
and all the containers definitions and
relationships everything is inside this
docker file here so you want to run two
containers that's totally fine instead
of running two commands now you just
have to run one file and that will do
take care of that now
you may be having more than two
containers five six seven whatever
number of containers you have that can
be easily deployed without any uh manual
activity or without any maintainers onto
the server
so uh these containers totally run in
isolation but yes you can establish the
interaction that how they want to uh
interact with each other and that
interaction you can put up in these uh
docker compose files so docker compose
file is something which is written in
the vml format and in this you define
that okay i need two containers and this
in this image should be there these are
the parameters which you need to run and
if you want to have the interaction or
the linkage between the images that also
you can establish within this yml files
or this in within this docker compose
file here right so let's say for example
i want to have an application which
requires apache web server and mysql
database now uh i can create a docker
compose file which can run both
containers and uh without you know you
don't require to restart or start them
separately or initialize them separately
so i will be having a final docker
compose file which is having like uh
you know containers like apache
containers and my mysql containers both
inside a single docker compose file here
so that's the benefit you're going to
get because now you don't have to run
them separately separate apache and
separate via mysql so you can get it
done with the help of a single docker
compose file here now what exactly is
the docker swamp now docker swam
is a inbuilt or it's a default
uh oxygen tool which is being provided
by the docker itself it's a service uh
for containers which allows the it
administrators and the developers to
create and manage a cluster of smart
nodes so um in a typical world when you
do the installation of docker there is a
limitation that you some of the features
like high ability multiple uh instances
or scalability all these things are not
possible as it is with the core docker
now on top of that you require the
organization tools like docker swamp
where you have a swam of node machines
are there on which you can have your
highly available application
infrastructure implemented now this one
means that if i want to run my
applications five containers six
containers and seven containers for that
purpose we are using the docker spam so
each node of docker swam is having a
docker daemon uh which is uh used to for
performing the interaction so there will
be a master node which is available so
uh it will be interacting with all the
known machine on the all the client
machines and this interaction will be in
such a way that it will let them know
okay i want to deploy the
container or onto the note 3 so it will
perform that activity and the container
will be up and running on the node three
there so a swamp consists of two type of
nodes one is the manager node and one is
the worker node so manager is the master
node which you can refer
and the worker node is the one which is
actually doing most of the work so uh
the manager node is not something which
is expected to host uh anything apart
from the main component but yes uh you
can always configure
if you feel that you want to only deploy
the container on the worker node so that
also you can uh do during the deployment
of the containers so manager will will
keep on connecting to the different
worker nodes there and whenever new
request comes in so it will basically
try to connect and see that okay i just
want to go ahead and deploy a container
so it will do the deployment of the
container on the worker node so the main
work will be done by the worker nodes
and manager is just doing the management
of all these resources the worker notes
will be definitely receiving the request
from the manager and uh it will be
proceeding and performing those
activities and uh
if for some reason worker node is not
active or online so the master node will
not be able to deploy the containers on
that server so right now let's talk
about a demo in which we have to create
a docker image using a docker file on
the open220 so uh you want to use a base
operating system as an ubuntu 20 there
and using that we will we are going to
create a custom docker image
so let's connect to our virtual machine
and see that how we can do that okay so
as part of this demo here we are going
to prepare a docker image and uh in that
we are going to use a base image of
ubuntu so uh let's take an operating
system of ubuntu 220 20 is the latest
version of the ubuntu operating system
so i have got a server so let's see so
first of all we have to install the
docker.io package which will install the
docker package and then we can
enable the
service we can make sure that the docker
service is up and running because if the
service itself is down then we will not
be able to perform any activity and then
our sample if you run docker run hello
hyphen world so that is going to pull a
docker image from the docker hub and a
particular activity will be done to you
so once that is done so we can say that
okay the container is up and running and
everything is got uh you know over there
up and running and then you can also try
some of the ubuntu uh docker image also
if you feel that you want to try you can
do that but the main uh demo which we
need to do over here is that we need to
prepare a custom docker image and in
this one we will be having like we will
be using an ubuntu base operating system
on top of that we will be installing php
and genix all these different components
so we are going to have a php based
website hosted onto the apache web
server as an nginx and then we will be
able to access that application so the
very first thing which we need to do is
that we need to create a folder uh let's
say that i just created a particular
folder called nginx hyphen image and
then i create a docker file over there
so docker file uh content we are going
to take from this one so let's go to the
server and see that how we can go ahead
with the activity
now uh what we can do is that uh what uh
we have got a server over here now in
this server what i am going to do is
that i am going to proceed with
installation of docker first now when i
do the docker installation first so what
will happen that i will be able to have
my docker installation completed and
then further on i can take the further
steps of having the accessibility of uh
going through the understanding that
what is this uh particular platform or
how to prepare different different kind
of containers so
i have got a particular container over
here so what i can really do is that i
can simply say that okay i have got a
server so this is a one-two server so
i'm going to run the command called app
update first now this will do the update
locally so all the links and everything
will be updated now the whole idea about
doing the updates is that so that i will
be able to ha establish the fact that
i'm trying to connect i'm trying to uh
connect with the 1.2 url so that at any
moment of time i should be able to fetch
on the latest packages now once that is
done so i'm going to run the command
called apt install docker dot io now the
moment i do this what will happen that
it will try to download some packages it
will ask for the confirmation you can
give your confirmation and i can say yes
the moment you give the confirmations
the download of the packages will
proceed over here step by step it will
download the packages and the
installation will go on now once the
installation is done so what you can do
is that you can see that docker is
deployed into your system or not you can
run docker version command or you can
also use the service command to check to
make sure to ensure that the docker
service is always up and running if the
service is not up and running you have
to make sure you have to enable it you
have to start that service so these are
some couple of steps which you need to
do in order to make sure that your uh
connectivity or your
environment is ready for with the docker
installation and once the docker
installation is done then only you will
be able to proceed further with the
further activities like preparing the
containers preparing the images and all
that stuff but if you don't have the
docker installed prior to that then
definitely it's going to be a problem so
just make sure that before even doing
any kind of activity before even doing
any kind of steps we ensure that the
docker is fully up and running so it's
going to take some time to download the
packages and we will wait for that and
once the installation is done we will
continue further on that part
okay now once the installation is done
so you can run the command call service
docker status and when you do that uh it
will let you know that whether the
docker service is available there or not
so uh you can start the service
in case you don't get uh the proper
response and
now you can see that it's showing up
that a process is running so earlier it
was not uh up and running it was
inactive but now it's active and you can
see here that dark ride is the process
which is running over here as an uh
process to initialize the docker daemon
so docker demon is up and running now
and we are good to go here so now uh if
we go and say like docker
run
hello hyphen vault so we are doing a
validation to our docker instance that
whether our docker instance is working
fine as expected or not because uh if
there is any kind of problem with the
docker demon and docker demand is not up
and running properly we would be able to
get an error message over there but
right now there is no error message
which represents that uh yes you are
pretty much running the docker image and
it's giving you the proper response so
you will be able to see the uh
docker images when you run so you will
be able to see that the docker image is
pulled down to your system and
definitely you have executed that and it
got you the response now the next thing
which we need to do is that we need to
run a particular
ubuntu one so for example if i go for
docker
run
iphone it
open to bash so what exactly we are
doing in this one is that we are pulling
down a ubuntu docker image and we are
running the bash executable on top of
that the whole purpose of doing that
activity is that so that if i want to do
some uh process or i want to perform
some activity i should be able to
connect to that darker image so the
moment i do this first of all if this
docker image is available locally that's
great it will immediately create the
container if the docker image is not
available locally the very first thing
which it will perform over here is to
pull down the docker image the correct
one and as you can see here that it uh
definitely pulls down the docker image
and once it is done so it got a terminal
for you now you can see it shows that
root at the id uh root at the rate one
id is there this id is nothing but it's
a container id which we are getting here
so definitely you are inside the docker
container and when you run the docker
when you run the exit command you will
see that you have come out of the docker
container over here and the moment you
run docker ps hyphen a command you can
actually see also that how many
container you deployed so far so you ran
hello world you ran the one to one both
of them are stopped there you can see
the exit zero in the status over here
because both of them are something which
you ran in the interactive mode so they
are done so if you want to keep your
container up and running you need to
have a container which runs in the dash
mode and always up and running but for
that you have to go ahead to the level
where we need to create a custom docker
image and do the setup accordingly so
let's see that how we can do that now
i'm going to create a particular folder
called nginx hyphen image
you can pretty much give any name
whatever name you feel you want to
perform you can do that now in this one
i'm going to put up a file called
dockerfile so let's see that what
content we need to put as such when you
talk about the dockerfile because
whatever content you put over here that
is what according which the docker image
will be prepared
now here
we have to talk about so first we have
to see a base image so we are saying
that okay
0.220.04 is what i want to use then we
are giving some labels now these labels
are used to give some information like
what is the version who is the
maintainer
what is the description uh you can do
the customizations to this one so
these labels are actually defined and
utilized so that i will be able to give
an information that okay so and so
developer is something which we can
contact so if there is any kind of
problem with the uh docker file or will
this uh build script we have to reach
out to that specific person so this is
what we typically do with the labels
here now um we also have to
uh set up a parameter like deviant
underscore fronted as in non-interactive
because whenever we talk about any build
process in dockerfile it it cannot be
there in the interactive session it
should be there in the non-interactive
and definitely a typical uh scenarios
like you can run app update command and
then we are installing the php and genex
super supervisor all these things we are
doing we are doing the installation uh
we are using the run attribute run a
particular step and in there whatever
the commands are executed these
statements will be executed when we will
be doing the build process and then we
are using some environment variables
okay so engine xp virtual host php
underscore conf engine extenders for
conf and supervisor underscore conf
these are the different environment
variables which we configuring over here
now next thing which we have is that uh
we have to transfer some files like
probably nginx and the virtual host file
we may have to transfer from our linux
server to the destination to the
docker container so for that we are
going to run some copy commands copy
statements so that we can do that stuff
and uh then definitely we are
transferring the supervisor
configuration file also to the server so
that we can have that configurations uh
setup over there and uh these are config
uh supervisor underscore conf and all
these different variables we have
already established where we are saying
that what exactly configuration we are
looking forward over here and then uh we
are uh you know creating some folder
structure we where www.html folder
structure we are creating so that we
will be able to push some content over
there and then we have the volume
configurations so whatever the volume
configurations are there we are putting
up so that um you know we will be able
to have all the uh specific direct
directories mounted on the host machine
on the whole server so that we can even
talk about locally also and then the
star.search is something which we need
to run because that's uh that will go
into the command statement which needs
to be executed because when you want to
run your process when you want to run
your engineering process or your docker
container some process should be up and
running that's where uh if any
interactive process will run then only
the docker container will be hold up so
that's what you can
do or you can configure over there so
i'm going to copy this whole content now
this whole content represents the
complete docker file so uh we have
already gone through this content one by
one but uh if we combine all these
content together till the exposed part
that's where we come up into these one
so expose we are doing atn 443 over here
right after this one we have to create
the uh host file virtual host file
supervisor d file and the star.search
file so let's go back to the server here
now
in this one you have to uh you can use
whatever editor you feel you want to use
you can do that
so this is what i will my
master file will look like you can see
i'm running some run commands
these are the environment variables i'm
using then further on this variables i'm
using just to define the paths okay so
you can see that this default file we
are copying from the uh host machine
from the server to the docker container
and then second file is super visor d
not con file and then we have star dot
sh file so these are the different files
which we want to configure here so once
this file is prepared we have to uh type
in or we have to create a default file
over here in this current directory so
in this current directory we have to put
up a file called default now in this one
we will be having the default virtual
host configuration config so we need to
put a server attribute
saying that we have to look forward for
index.html or index.php and these kind
of files from the www.html directory
there so i'm just going to copy this
content
and
put it up into this one
so this is how my final file look like
so i'll save it
and uh then we have a supervisord dot
com file so
so i'll just copy the content of this
one
i'll copy it and we have to create a
file called
supervisor d.confile
now names we can double check because we
are referring these names into our
docker file so
we can double check that so once this is
done
save it
and we can check the docker file you can
grab
so you can see okay this one so super
wiser d so the name is correct that
scroll so we got default we got
supervisor d now we have to create the
star dot sh file because in this one we
will be configuring that how we want to
start our process of this nginx or this
web server so in this one again we have
to run the uh supervised process over
here and a configuration file so we are
going to put this one
and we'll go here and put this content
right so we got the supervised config
also available so that's also there and
the moment is done so you are going to
give the execute permission to this one
because um you can see that into our
docker file that we are having the
attribute where we want to run this into
the dots
slash there so if you want to refer in
that mode you have to change the
permissions in case so that
change mode you have to give the execute
permission to the start dot sh here now
once this is done
so what you got is that you got a
particular uh components like you got uh
some couple of commands you have uh you
know
got docker file super isd.conf default
all these files are there now the only
thing which we need to do next is that
we need to build to the build process
so uh if we look forward for the build
process what happens that docker build
is the command which we need to use and
uh nginx iphone image is the name which
you want to refer now you can totally
use this uh custom name you whatever
name you feel that you want to use you
can always use that there's no
restriction on that part and once that
is on so you will be able to list down
those images that you got a new custom
docker image here so you can see that
you got the ubuntu as a base image which
is built down and the nginx iphone image
is also prepared over there
and once that is done so you are going
to create a web root folder and uh you
can run the docker run command to see
that if you really got connected with
that particular one so let's go back and
uh see that how we can create uh the
docker custom docker image here so the
moment i do this so it will pick up the
docker file over here and start
performing the activities uh the package
installations all those configurations
ones will be performed over here in a
non-interactive mode there is no
confirmation which will be asked from
the user because you cannot put that
confirmations so the command should be
in such a way that it should not take
any kind of confirmations at all from
the
end user so because tomorrow you may be
putting up these things in the jenkins
so that will not be a feasible thing for
you to put up the commands and put up
the
confirmations during the execution so so
it's trying to run do the package
installation for the php so fbm packages
are getting installed and um
here we go so we caught the successful
message now you can see it says
successfully tag this one this means
that there is no issues at all with the
docker image and when you run the darker
images or docker images ls you can run
these two couple of commands so when you
do that you got a 203 37 mb of the size
of this image that represents that this
docker image is fully ready to run to
execute
so now what we are going to do is that
we are going to map a volume over here
with the bad wwe html directory during
the execution of this container because
i really want to deploy some pages some
web pages there if you have the web
pages now as part of the build process
as part of the docker file you can do a
git clone also of some repository but i
don't want to do that uh during the
preparation of docker image i just now
got an environment where the nginx is
set up properly and it's up and running
there now it should be upon me that how
i want to put up my content and all so
that's the reason why i'm putting up a
kind of a folder structure over here and
sharing it with the docker container so
that the moment i put that the html
files or the php files into that local
folder i should be able to get some
webpage up and running there so that's
what i'm going to do over here in this
one so i'm going to create a folder
structure saying slash
web root here okay so there is a folder
structure which is created now in this
web route i will be putting up some
files and then same files will be
redirected inside the docker container
with the help of docker volume so let's
go back to the document now here
you have to run uh the uh once like i
said that
you are going to connect on that part
okay so uh you can use this port as an
80 also but here 8080 is used so
whatever port you feel you want to use
you can do that and we are giving the
container name as test and iphone
container that also you can change and
generic syphon image is the one which we
are using so if you use some different
uh particular image you can also use
that and uh you can see that the web
root is something which we are
connecting with the www html directory
so the moment you put some file in the
web root the same file will be reflected
into the
www.html directory there so i'm going to
run this command and once this is done
so you can see that for the testing
purpose we are putting up some content
in the html one so i'll come to that
point also and we'll validate as of now
we should be having our container up and
running over here in this one now i'm
going to copy that command
okay and hit on so if uh the 80 port is
used so you have to make sure that port
gets uh you know gets stopped
automatically or it should not be up and
running so just double check whatever
code you're using that should be free
now when you run the docker ps command
so uh you will be able to see a docker
container up and running but if you see
like docker psyphony that gives also the
stopped and running both the containers
are there but the main thing which we
want to run is that we want to run the
docker ps command and you can see that
this is a container which is running so
8080 is the container which is running
and test hyphen container is the name
now you've got a container up and
running so you can actually do a call on
localhost colon 8080 so um this is a way
to get the content
you can get the public ip also and in
the browser you can put up and you can
have the content there but right now we
are getting the response at least uh
it's showing his 403 error forbidden
error but that's fine we will be putting
up some web pages there in the rwb html
directory or we can say in local web
root directory so that we will be able
to have some content so what we can do
is that we can have some echo commands
executed so that we can have some added
some content added up into the uh
particular uh files there so let's see
that what different contents we can do
so uh you can use the vi mode also to do
a uh you know couple of files so
i'm just using this echo command
so um
the moment i go for this execution so
what happens that a file will be created
into that uh slash web root there so um
i'm expecting that i have put up
index.html page so if you feel that you
want to put some different page you can
always do and uh the moment you do the
curl now you will be able to see the
same response so whatever the things you
put up in the index.html file the same
content is going to pop up when you run
the curl command now um you want to use
some php files you want to put up some
php content all that stuff you can do it
now what i'm going to do is that rather
than just a html static content i'm
going to put some php content that
is going to help me to get a file so my
web root will have now two files so um
if if you feel
uh that index.html file should have some
meaningful content you can always do
that you can pull some of the websites
also you can put that into the you can
do a git clone in the web root and the
whole application will be started and uh
now
if you feel that i got a info.php file
so i can use the nut name into the url i
have to modify the url because uh
index.html file is the what as in
default name page you do if you want to
put up some different name you can
change the server configuration of nginx
and according to that it will work
so um when i do this so you will start
getting the output so this is the php
content output which is there it's a
complete information now it may look
like a very bulky content to you but
when you put up this one into the
browser into the web browser that will
be a meaningful information probably in
terms of some tables or something like
that right so um let me scroll to the
top here so you can see that it's
showing an error sorry it's showing in
the output and this output represents
that you got a particular php content
here so this is how we will be able to
have a container and uh you know this
container is up and running you can
modify to at any level you feel that you
want to prepare a darker image with the
code embedded also
you can have the git clone or you can
have this configuration into some git
repository have the source code also
there and then prepare a complete bundle
altogether so this is what we have in
this demo how we can deploy a container
and a container up and running in case
of the docker here why you would want to
consider using a docker container in
your devops environment so let's have a
look at what we have in our current
environment so today when you actually
have your standard machine you have the
infrastructure you have the host
operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly the
different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest os and we're able
to eliminate the hypervisor environment
and this is really important as we
actually start working and creating
environments that are consistent because
we want to be able to make it so it's
really easy and stable for the
environment that you have within your
dev and ops environment now critical is
getting rid of that hypervisor element
it's just a lot of overhead so let's
have a look at a container as an example
so here we actually have a couple of
examples on the right hand side we have
different containers we have one
containers running apache tomcat and
with java a second container is running
sql server and microsoft.net environment
the third container is running python
with mysql these are all running just
fine within the docker engine and
sitting on top of a host os which could
be linux it really could be any host os
within a consistent infrastructure and
you're able to have a solution that can
be shared easily amongst your teams so
let's have a look at an example that
you'd have today if a company is doing a
traditional java application so you have
your developers working in jboss on his
system and he's coding away and he has
to get that code over to a tester now
what will happen is that tester will
then typically in your traditional
environment then have to install jboss
on their machine and get everything
running and cool and hopefully set up
identically to the developer chances are
they probably won't have it exactly the
same but they're trying to get as close
as possible and then at some point you
want to be able to test this within your
production environment so you send it
over to a system administrator who would
then also have to install jboss on their
environment as well yeah this just seems
to be a whole lot of duplication so why
go through the problem of installing
jboss three times
and this is where it things get really
interesting because the challenge you
have today is that it's very difficult
to almost impossible to have identical
environments if you're just installing
software locally on devices the
developers probably got a whole bunch of
development software that could be
conflicting with the jboss environment
the tester has similar testing software
but probably doesn't have all the
development software and certainly the
system administrator won't have all the
tools that the developer and tester have
their own tools and so what you want to
be able to do is kind of get away from
the challenge you have of having to do
local installations on three different
computers and in addition what you see
is that this uses up a lot of effort
because when you're having to install
software over and over again you just
keep repeating doing really basic
foundational challenges so this is where
docker comes in and docker is the tool
that allows you to be able to share
environments from one group to another
group without having to install software
locally on a device you install all of
the code into your docker container and
simply share the container so in this
presentation we're going to go through a
few things we're going to cover what
docker actually is and then we're going
to dig into the actual architecture of
docker and kind of go through what
docker container is and how to create a
docker container and then we'll go out
through the benefits of using docker
containers and then the commands and
finalize everything out with a brief
demo so what is docker so docker is as
you'd expect because all the software
that we cover in this series is an open
source solution and it is a container
solution that allows you to be able to
containerize all of the necessary files
and applications needed to run the
solution you're building so you can
share it from different people in your
team whether it's a developer tester or
system administrator and this allows you
to have a consistent environment from
one group to the next so let's kind of
dig into that architecture so you
understand why docker runs effectively
so the docker architecture itself is
built up of two key elements there is
the docker client and then there is a
rest api connection to a docker daemon
which actually hosts the entire
environment within the docker host and
the docker demon you have your different
containers and each one has a link to a
docker registry the docker client itself
is a rest service so as you'd expect a
rest api and that sends command line to
the docker daemon through a terminal
window or command line interface window
and we'll go through some of these demos
later on so you can actually see how you
can actually interact with darker the
docker demo then checks the request
against and the docker components and
then performs the service that you're
requesting now the docker image itself
all it really is a collection of
instructions used to create a container
and again this is consistent with all
the devops tools that we have the devops
tools that we're looking to use
throughout this series of videos are all
environments that can be scripted and
this is really important because it
allows you to be able to duplicate and
scale the environments that you want to
be able to build very quickly and
effectively the actual container itself
has all of the applications and the
dependencies of those applications in
one package you can kind of think of it
as a really effective and efficient zip
file it's a little bit more than that
but it's one file that actually has
everything you need to be able to run
all of your solutions the actual docker
registry itself is an environment for
being able to host and distribute
different docker images among your team
so say for instance you had a team of
developers that were working on multiple
different solutions so say you have a
team of developers and you have 50
developers and they're working on five
different applications you can actually
have the applications themselves the
containers shared in the docker registry
so each of those teams at any time check
out and have the latest container of
that latest image of the code that
you're working on so let's dig into what
actually is in the container so the
important part of a docking container is
that it has everything you need to be
able to run the application it's like a
virtualized environment it has all your
frameworks and your libraries and it
allows the teams to be able to build out
and run exactly the right environment
that the developer intended what's
interesting though is the actual
applications then will run in isolation
so they're not impacting other
applications that using dependencies on
other libraries or files outside of the
container because of the architecture it
really uses a lot less space and because
it's using less space it's a much more
lightweight architecture so the files
the actual folder itself is much smaller
it's very secure highly portable and the
boot up time is incredibly fast so let's
actually get into how you would actually
create a docker container so the docker
container itself is actually built
through command line and it's built of a
file and docker image so the actual
docker file is a text file that contains
all the instructions that you would need
to be able to create that docker image
and then we'll actually then create all
of the project code with inside of that
image then the image becomes the item
that you would share through the docker
registry you would then use the command
line and we'll do this later on select
docker run and then the name of the
image to be able to easily and
effectively run that image locally and
again once you've created the docker
image you can store that in the docker
registry making it available to anybody
within your network so something to bear
in mind is that docker itself has its
own registry called docker hub and that
is a public registry so you can actually
go out and see other docker images that
have been created and access those
images as your own company you may want
to have your own private um repository
so you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of docker hub where you
can actually then share those files
now something that's also very
interesting to know is that you can have
multiple versions of a docker image so
if you have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a docker
image using some of our basic docker
commands
and so there are essentially really you
know kind of just two commands that
you're going to be looking for one is
the build command another one is to
actually put it into your registry which
is a push command so if you want to get
a image from a docker registry then you
want to use the pull command and a pull
command simply pulls the image from the
registry and in this example using uh
nginx as our registry and we can
actually then pull the image down to our
test environment on our local machine so
we're actually running the container
within our docker application on our
local machine we're able to then have
the image run exactly as it would in
production and then you can actually use
the run command to actually use the
docker image on your local machine so
just a you know a few uh interesting
tidbits about the docking container once
the container is created a new layer is
formed on top of the docker image layers
called the container layer each
container has a separate read write
container layer and any changes made in
that docking container is then reflected
upon the particular container layer and
if you want to delete the container
layer the container layer also gets
deleted as well so you know why would
using docker and containers be of
benefit to you well you know some of the
things that are useful is that
containers have no external dependencies
for the applications they run once you
actually have the container running
locally it has everything it needs to be
able to run the application so there's
no having to install additional pieces
of software such as the example we gave
with jpos at the beginning of the
presentation now the containers are
really lightweight so it makes it very
easy to share the containers amongst
your teams whether it's a developer
whether it's a tester whether it's
somebody on your operations environment
it's really easy to share those
containers amongst your entire team
different data volumes can be easily
reused and shared among
multiple containers and again this is
another big benefit and this is a
reflection of the lightweight nature of
your containers the container itself
also runs in isolation
which means that it is not impacted by
any dependencies you may have on your
own local environment so it's a
completely sandboxed environment so some
of the questions you might ask us you
know can you run multiple containers
together without the need to start each
one individually and you know what yes
you can with docker compose docking
compose allows you to run multiple
containers in a single service and again
this is a reflection on the lightweight
nature of containers within the docker
environment so we're going to end our
presentation by looking at some of the
basic commands that you'd have within
docker so we have here on the left hand
side we have a docker container and then
the command for each item we're actually
going to go ahead and use some of these
commands in the demo that we're going to
do after this presentation you'll see
that in a moment but just you know some
of the basic commands we have are
committing the docket image into the
container kill is a you know standard
kill command to you know terminate one
or more of the running containers so
they stopped working then restart those
containers but suddenly you can look at
all the image all of the commands here
and try them out for yourself so we're
going to go ahead and start a demo of
how to use the basic commands to run
docker so to do this we're going to open
up terminal window or command line
deploying whether you're running linux
pc or mac and we're going to go ahead
and the first thing we want to do is see
what our docker image lists are so we
can go sudo docker images and this will
give us well first we'll enter in our
password so let's go enter that in and
this one that gives us a list of our
docker images and here are the docker
images that have already been created in
the system and we can actually go ahead
and actually see the processes that are
actually running so i'm going to go
ahead and open up this window a little
bit more but this will show you the
actual processes and the containers that
we actually have and so on the far left
hand side you see under names we have
learn simply learn be underscore cool
these are all just different ones that
we've been working on so let's go ahead
and create a docker image so i'm gonna
do sudo
docker
run
0.0.0.0
go on 80 colon 80
ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run an ubuntu
image and this will run the latest image
and what we have here is a hash number
and this hash number is a unique name
that defines the container that we've
just created and we can go ahead and we
can check to make sure that the
container actually is present so we're
going to do
sudo docker.ps and this actually shows
sound there so it's not in a running
state right now but that doesn't mean
that we don't have it so let's list out
all the containers that are both running
and in the exit state so let's do sucker
ps dash a and
this lists all the containers that i
have running on my machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running state and in the
exit stage and here we see one that we
just created about a minute ago and it's
called learn
and these are all running ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go
so let's change that to that new dock
container to a running state so scroll
down
and we're going to type sudo
docker
run
dash
i t dash dash
name
my
um
so this is going to be the new container
name it's going to be my docker so this
is how we name our docker environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
ubuntu
and bin dash bash
and it's now in our route and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my docker container so sudo
docker
start
my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that docker
image
and let's go ahead and check against the
other running docker images to make sure
it's running correctly so sudo docker
ps
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side you actually see my
docker along with the other docker
images that we created that's been
running for 13 seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker
rename we can take another docker image
this grab this one and we'll put it in
rename
and we'll rename i'm putting the old
container name which is image and then
we'll put in the new container name and
let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
proved something called image is now
called purple
so we do sudo docker
ps
to list all of our docker images
and we scroll up and there there we go
purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop containers so we're
going to write sudo docker
stop
and then we have to put in the container
name and we'll put in my docker the
container that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still
there as an image is just
not in an active stage it's what's known
as in an exit state
so here we go
and there's my ducker it's in an exit
state so that happened 27 seconds ago
so if we want to to remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker
rm
we'll remove
my docker
and that will remove it from the exit
state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and yep
yep
it's not not listed there under exit
state anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there that's where it used to be
all right
let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do pseudo kill and
then the name of the container
i think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's gonna
kill it
oops no i guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of
container that we actually have
so pseudo
docker
kill
oh we're gonna list out the ones that
are running oh okay there we go now
yellow isn't in that list so let's take
i know let's take simply learn and so we
can actually go ahead and let's write
sudo docker
kill
simply learn
and that will actually kill an active
docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now
that's the simply learn container is not
active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
docker container
did you know before docker and
containers were introduced companies had
been deploying their software either on
a bare metal or in a virtual machine
but they had been facing a lot of
challenges in managing orchestration of
services instant deployment of services
on different platforms and maintaining
multi-host applications
all these issues were solved with the
help of docker and its containers
in this docker and container tutorial
session
we will give you the conceptual exposure
to docker and its containers
we will focus on why is docker container
essential
what is docker container what exactly is
virtualization
then few significant differences between
vm and docker container
then some of the benefits of using a
docker container
architecture of docker
next how docker container works in the
docker ecosystem
and finally a step-by-step process in
how to create docker containers
let's begin with the first topic do you
know why docker containers are essential
in an organization
consider an example where a company
develops a code on oracle weblogic
software
in the company a developer installs
oracle weblogic software on his computer
system
once the application is developed he
shares it with the other team for
testing the code
now the tester repeats the weblogic
installation process which was done by
the developer earlier on his system
later the same application file is
shared with the production team
to host the application the system admin
must install oracle web logic on his
system
let me ask you an important question
here
have you noticed that the same weblogic
installation process was done thrice
but what could be the reason behind it
due to the difference in computer
environments web logic doesn't work on
the other systems so installation is
done separately on three different
computers
but this process of installing the same
software on different systems consume a
lot of time and effort
in order to avoid these problems docker
containers were introduced before we
start with the concept of docker
containers let me explain you what a
docker is docker is an open source
platform that helps a user package and
application and its dependencies into a
docker container to develop and deploy
software docker provides suitable
frameworks for different applications
since every application has a framework
with an appropriate version this space
also can be utilized for a new software
application along with its required
framework
as a result docker makes more efficient
use of system resources
containerization includes all
dependencies frameworks libraries etc
required to run an application in an
efficient and bug-free manner
with docker containers applications can
work efficiently in different computer
environments
after this let's talk about the benefits
the benefits of docker containers show
up in many places
containers are widely used because of
their services
since it's lightweight it can be easily
deployed and executed on other computer
environments regardless of their host
operating system or configurations
containers take up less disk space and
relatively faster in executing
applications
containers run applications in isolation
and also share the operating system
kernel with other containers
by default containers are entirely
secure
container policies ensure all
applications are highly secure including
the docker infrastructure containers are
highly portable and can run anywhere
across the docker ecosystem multiple
software can be encapsulated in a single
container and can be easily deployed to
different platforms
as soon as a container is created it can
be deployed into any other system where
docker is already installed
on that system the application will
perform exactly as it did in the
previous environment
containers take less boot up time
these containers save time in the
deployment process of an application
here comes the next important concept
virtualization
virtualization is the technology of
running a virtual instance of a computer
system or running a virtual version of a
computer resource like hardware software
storage devices and computer network
resources on the cloud
a virtual machine is an isolated
computing environment that allows
developers to use an operating system
via a pc or computer system
let's now talk about some of the
significant benefits of using docker
containers
the first benefit is the lack of
external dependency
containers have no external dependency
for applications to run
containers will just be used to host and
run the applications
as containers are lightweight they are
quickly shipped to other computers and
execute it in different computer
environments regardless of their host
operating systems
containers are lightweight they share a
kernel across containers and therefore
use less memory space the next benefit
is the volume
volumes are also a convenient way to
share data within the docker ecosystem
volumes can be more safely shared among
other containers
and the last one is isolation
containers run application in isolation
and share the operating system kernel
with other containers
in containers the host operating system
provides isolation along with the
applications microservices can also be
more easily isolated
next comes the most important topic of
the session that is
containerization versus virtualization
containerization and virtualization are
two different ways to deploy
applications and microservices in a
computer environment in vms a hypervisor
is a firmware layer that enables
multiple operating system to run side by
side
a virtual machine has unstable
performance as multiple running vms run
simultaneously on the same machine
also the efficiency of hypervisors is
not as good as that of the host
operating system
due to the extra layer in vm an
application takes quite a long time to
start
as you can see there are two
architectures on the screen on the left
hand side is vm and on the right hand
side is the docker
on the left hand side as you see there
is one host operating system a
hypervisor and guest operating system
shared by all containers along with
their dependencies
in vm guest operating system occupies
more space and leads to unstable
performance
guest operating system makes virtual
machines less efficient than the
physical machines
guest operating system makes a vm slow
because they access the hardware
indirectly
on the other hand docker is efficient
unlike vms docker doesn't have a
hypervisor or guest operating system
docker consists of containers
these containers are efficient and are
easily portable across different
platforms
in vms the hypervisor has a scalability
issue the hypervisor creates a security
risk as well
well
do you know that according to vettana
the chances of experiencing a data
breach while using virtualization are
high
well
that could lead to a major problem for
companies who are still using virtual
machines
next
let's have a closer look at the docker
containers
in case you are unsure what kind of
applications can be added to a container
then look on the right hand side
a container can package apache tomcat
and its dependency that is java
programming language in a single file
later a user can ship the container to
another computer environment and run the
code without any issue
it's usually challenging to understand
the differences between container and vm
so let me explain to you the differences
in layman terms as shown the virtual
machine is compared to a bangla and the
container is considered as an apartment
in a bungalow amenities like water lift
roof etc cannot be shared with the
neighbors
likewise vm is less efficient it doesn't
share its resources with other
applications
on the other hand containers share their
amenities binaries and libraries with
the neighboring containers just like a
person who resides in an apartment
the bank law is owned by a single person
it cannot have tenants
likewise virtual machines cannot run
multiple applications
on the other side docker runs multiple
containers just like numerous tenants
reside in a single building
next let's look at the table in which we
have made a direct comparison between
virtual machines and containers
in docker containers data volumes can be
shared and reused among multiple
containers
either docker cli or docker api manages
the volumes
also the volume drivers give the
facility of storing volumes on remote
hosts or cloud providers
vm is a container based model it
utilizes user space along with the
kernel space of an operating system so
data volumes cannot be shared
containers have a better performance as
they are hosted in a single docker
engine
docker provides the most substantial
default isolation capabilities among the
other configuration tools making the
performance better
virtual machines run multiple vms at a
time which leads to unstable performance
docker is much more efficient than
hypervisors
docker enables developers to wrap ship
quickly and run applications as a
lightweight and portable container
on the other hand virtual machines are
less efficient
docker containers can run multiple
containers on a system but virtual
machine can run only a limited number of
vms on a system
multiple software can be encapsulated in
a single container and can be easily
deployed to different platforms
containers are easily portable across
other platforms but virtual machines
have compatibility issues while porting
others across different platforms
moving on to the next one let's have a
look at the architecture of docker
a docker or docker engine consists of
two major components
docker client and docker demon
these two components are connected to
each other with the help of the rest api
now let's take a look at the
architecture
a docker client has no components but a
docker daemon consists of a docker host
docker daemon docker registry and docker
images
docker client is a service that uses
rest api to send commands to docker
demon through cli commands
rest api is a primary mode of
communication between docker client and
docker daemon
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
docker daemon checks the client's
request and communicates with the docker
components to perform a service
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
docker image is also one of the
essential components of docker
a docker image is a file of instructions
that are used to create containers
a docker image is built using a file
called dockerfile
a docker image is a template of
instructions that is used to create
containers
coming to containers
a docker container is a portable
executable package that includes
applications and their dependencies
docker containers are lightweight
because they do not require an extra
layer of a hypervisor and run directly
on the host operating system
there is a service in docker called
docker compose
a docker compose is used for running
multiple containers as a single service
in compose service each container runs
in isolation but can interact with each
other with no limitations
talking about docker registry it is a
service used for hosting and
distributing docker images among users
docker registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among users
let's move on and understand how to
create a docker container
first ensure to set up your development
environment then you can begin to
develop containerized applications
for that you need to create a docker
image a docker image can be created
using a docker file a docker image is
created using a build command
you must build a docker image that
contains the code of what your
application needs to run
in simple terms a docker image contains
all the project's code
with docker image you can run the code
to develop docker containers
once the docker image is created ensure
to store it in the docker registry using
the docker push command
once a docker image is created you can
either store it in a docker hub or in a
repository
docker also has its default registry
called docker hub
there are multiple docker images
available in the registry and all can be
retrieved through the dockable command
as soon as a docker image is retrieved
from the docker registry you can build
new containers
moving on to the next one let's
understand how docker containers work
in docker a dockerfile is used to build
the image using the build command and
that image is stored in the registry
using the push command
when you run the pull command docker
image is retrieved from the registry
while a single container is built using
docker image through the run command
did you know that a new layer is formed
on top of the docker image layers called
the container layer when a container is
created
this new layer consists of the
application and its dependencies
in docker each container has a separate
reader write container layer
any modifications done in a docker
container are reflected upon the
container layer
suppose a container is deleted the
container layer also gets permanently
deleted
this was the simple functionality of
docker and containers
in this one we are going to see that how
we can make use of the docker files to
prepare a docker image
and using which we can create a docker
container
so uh we are going to talk about what is
a docker what is a docker file what is
this index of docker file and how to
build a custom docker image with the
help of docker file and in the end we
are going to see a particular demo
related to the docker files over here
now let's talk about what is the docker
now docker is in configuration
management tool which we are pretty much
using to prepare the automation of the
deployment of the
software of the applications now in this
case we make use of the docker
containers using which we can host our
applications and within these docker
containers we are typically hosting both
the application source code and the
differences all together so both the
dings are getting packaged all together
into a single unit called docker
containers and getting hosted onto the
server
these containers are very efficient in
work because they are not taking that
much utilization and resources and at
the same time they can be shared across
different environments also so the same
container can be easily deployed across
different different
uh environments as such
now it helps us to maintain the isolated
application it uh helps in having a high
productivity there and it also you know
helps us to see to resolve all the
problems which is related to the uh
dependencies for your software because
we are packaging up both the source code
and the dependencies all together in the
single unit in the single entity and
that's where you will be able to get a
particular final solution called as in
docker container over here so docker
container is in complete package using
which you can have like both the
applications and the dependencies bundle
up together into a single entity and
that's where we call it as a docker
container
now what exactly is an uh docker that uh
you know let's see a particular
difference between the virtual machine
and the docker here now if you see on
the left hand side we have the host
operating system
uh which is available there let's say i
have a laptop in this one we have a
windows 10
now we have a hypervisor on top of that
like how hypervisor is in software which
is used to manage the virtual machines
it's a software which is available there
which takes up all the requests from the
virtual machines process it and then
give the response back so hypervisor
acts like a medium between the virtual
machine and the host operating system
resources so
it's going to give that a particular
virtual environment to the virtual
machines
and then we have a virtual machines
where in fact a guest operating system
is there then application binaries then
the application is hosted so this guest
operating system actually takes up a lot
of utilization
and these was the old mechanism where we
used to uh
follow this mechanism for hosting our
applications
so all the applications are pretty much
getting deployed in the same manner on
the form of the virtual machines here
right now
if you talk about the new method which
we are talking about right now is in
docker so here we have host operating
system but instead of hypervisor we have
now the docker engine which is available
there now this docker engine is
something which is making sure working
in the same way that how the hypervisor
is behaving but it's much lighter as
compared to the hypervisor
so docker is very lightweight as
compared to the hypervisor here
and here we don't have the concept of
the heavy duty guest operating system
over here so the guest operating systems
which we are using in case of docker
containers are very small in size
the size of guest operating systems is
is in gb's in case of virtual machine
but in case of docker containers it's
pretty much available in the mb size
which is there so the size of the guest
operating system in case of the virtual
machine is really small as compared to
the virtual machine
and that's a biggest benefit because
again it will
help the containers to have a low
utilization low consumptions and uh that
improves the overall performance of the
overall mechanisms and how exactly the
new method of application deployment
really helps us to go for an a
particular advanced mechanism so that
brings on a very good and the efficient
uh way of doing the deployment of the
applications
now let's talk about what exactly is in
dockerfile here now docker file is a
concept which is being used as in build
script so it's being used so that we can
have a build a script there
so this will definitely helps uh to see
that how we can go for a build of a
docker image a custom docker image
now when we are using the dockerfile uh
concept so it really helps to prepare a
kind of docker image
so dock image is the end result when you
are going for the mechanism when you're
going for the docker file build up oh
yeah so docker file is a built script
which is available for preparing the
custom docker containers because not
every docker image is available on
docker hub so some containers you have
to use some images you have to use to
work on that part
now docker file is a very simple
straightforward text file which is
available there and it's basically used
to build up custom docker images so
docker file is basically used to prepare
a once so when you're running the docker
build so it's actually going to build up
a particular custom docker image and
that will be given to you
so docker uh image is the whole build
process which is being done
so it's a custom process which is
available and being done over here in
this case
so you got a docker file you run the
docker build command and that's how you
will be able to get a docker image so
whatever the steps you are having in the
docker file that will be processed one
by one and as a end result you will be
able to get a full flesh docker image
over here in this case
right now let's talk about the syntax of
the docker file so docker file is equal
to commands commands and the arguments
so whatever the things you want to put
up so in the docker file you can do that
and as a part of the execution so you
will be able to get a particular end
result
now it's a kind of a mechanism where we
feel that how the execution and the
modifications can be done
so uh the comments which we are trying
to do over here is that you know we can
put up the whatever the comments we want
to put in the case of docker files we
can do that comments is a standard
process in uh preparing any particular
file or any kind of code because it
helps us to understand that for what
reason we are preparing that particular
line then uh we have the uh particular
run statements the commands are there so
you can see that we are running a
particular command called eco so using
the run attribute we are basically going
ahead and running a particular command
into our system as part of our docker
file over here
now how to build up the docker images
using the docker file so um you know
docker file is uh just a template which
is available there where we are putting
up that what are the different steps we
want to follow and these steps when we
follow one by one step by step so that's
where we will be able to get a
particular final docker container over
here so docker image is getting
converted as a docker container and we
are getting a docker container as an end
result
now
docker file is being built up and uh
stored in the version control system and
uh this particular docker files when we
are processing so it prepares a
respective a specific image layer over
here and this image layer is something
which is
benefiting us that how the executions
can be done and how we can manage on
that part
so
that really helps us to see that how the
executions and the things can be managed
and that can help us to see that how the
management of the things can be
performed as such
so uh docker file is a very good concept
which is there using which you can
prepare any kind of custom docker image
and it can be very easily handle also
and it's in fully automated mechanism
you can use it inside the cicd pipelines
for automating the docker images
right now it's a docker image is a layer
by layer mechanism which is there in
which we have multiple layers each and
every layer we are doing some specific
entries some specific tasks or some you
know changes we are trying to deploy in
part of our these layers right so uh
you can use the uh particular docker
build command to perform the executions
and you will be able to get any
particular response an output will be
given back to you so docker file is
basically helping you to see that how
the executions can be done and you will
be able to get an end result over here
so the docker image is the final result
which we are getting when we are talking
about the docker file here
right so these are all read-only formats
which are available you cannot modify
these directly but yes with the help of
docker file you can do whatever the
changes you want to deploy on these
docker images
right so uh this is a small example
where we are using a base image as an 1
to 18.04 so we are using the from
attribute to specify that yes we are
going to use the ubuntu 18.04 here then
we are pulling our
the file into the uh directory we are
transferring a particular file inside
the docker container and then we are
running our make command and then cmd
attribute is there using which we can
run the command on the runtime on the
docker container so these are a very a
basic example but eventually when we are
done with this darker image we will be
able to get a four layer uh docker image
over here because there are four steps
and then hence it will be providing you
a particular four layers in your final
docker image over here so layer by layer
these changes will be done during the
build process and in fact using the
docker history command you can see the
layers these layers information also
right so layer 1 is ubuntu 18.04 layer 2
is pull and the third layer is there
where we can run the uh make command to
you know run this file which we have
pulled on and then the finally the last
one is there where we are running like
using the cmd parent so the difference
between run and cmd is that cmd will run
only when you run a docker container so
run attribute will be executed during
the docker build part
so this is a pretty much is a way that
how we can go for the execution of a
docker file and how you know we can go
for the uh build up of a custom docker
image over here so these are the for
some couple of attributes which we are
using in the docker file here
right now let's talk about the entry
point over here now entry point allows
you to specify a command along with the
parameters right so uh let's say that
you want to run a particular command uh
over here in the docker container so
entry point is something which you can
use to refer to that so application is
the command which you're trying to run
and then you can give some arguments to
that and argument one is what you are
trying to run over here
so entry point is very important because
that eventually helps to see that how
the executions can be done
and the implementations will be done
over here in this case
right so you can see like you can run a
command called eco and then you can use
the parameters also it's not like only
the commands can be used but you can in
fact use the arguments also now add is
an attribute which is available in the
docker file which is primary used to see
to uh transfer the files from the host
machine inside the docker image
now let's see that you are trying to
prepare your own custom docker image
apart from the dependencies you need the
source code also right so the source
code needs to be transferred inside the
docker image and for that reason we can
use the add attribute so add attribute
requires a source and destination source
will always be the path on which uh on
the destin on the host machine the files
are present so we can give that
and destination is the folder which is
available inside the uh particular
docker container where we want to store
the files so you can use the example
over here just like this you can use and
you can give two entries one is the
source one is the destination and once
that is done so you will be able to see
your files being stored up in the
destination directory once the final
docker image is prepared
then we have enb attribute uh now enb is
something which is used to set up some
environment variables which is required
of course for the docker image for the
application which is running inside the
docker image now environment variables
are something which you can hardcore
during the docker build one but using
the when you are running like when
you're creating the docker container at
that time also you can override the
these environment variables so
environment variables are very important
because uh first during the build
process you can hard code some values
but if you really want to change them
during the runtime that also is being
supported by the environment variables
so
most of the times we use it as an kind
of a keep value pair just like in linux
we use uh we use to set up a particular
environment variable so the key value
pair is being used in case of enb
attribute
maintainer is there where we can
describe that what is the details about
the author these are the fields which is
available in the top so where we can
give the the author name and the author
you know details like email id and all
so that we know that who is the person
who is maintaining this particular file
and we can reach out to them in case any
issues are there for the docker files am
right so that is what we have here in
this one so now we are going to see that
how we can go for a small demo and
docker file and we can go for the
implementation of this
particular docker file and prepare a
custom docker image so let's just wait
on that part
so let's see some demo here now in this
one we have got two examples one is the
python one is the notice one so first of
all what we need to do is that we need
to process the python one here so this
is the sample docker file which we have
got here for the python now all this one
requires a python file which is already
present on the server and we are going
to transfer we are going to copy this
content over here that this is the
specific docker file content which is
available to us and all we need to do is
that we need to put this content across
the server so that we will be able to
build our custom docker image so let's
go back to the server so here we have
already got the python file which is
present so we have to create a docker
file here which will have the steps
related to the docker image preparation
over here so we will be including some
steps over here that these are the
different steps we want to configure we
want to set up over here in this one so
python 3.6.4 is the version of the
python which we want to configure and
then we are going to transfer some files
into slash app we are also setting up
the working directory as slash app and
ultimately we are running a command
called pip install flask to do the
installation of flash package and then
we are starting the uh specific
applications on that part so i'm going
to save this file and uh once i save
this file so all we need to do is that
we need to create a custom docker image
right so right now there is no image
which is available over here and it's in
complete md instance so i'm going to run
a command called docker
build
hyphen t
python hyphen m dot so docker build is
the typical command but hyphen t is for
the tag that what kind of docker image
you want to build and then we are giving
a image name and then we are specifying
dot over there now once we are done with
that so it will pick up all the things
one by one the basic docker image is
being pulled down then some sequence of
steps is being executed so it's a
step-by-step process which is happening
over here in this case and we are then
transferring some files in the slash app
and then ultimately we are going for the
pip install flask so it's installing
those packages and at the end the final
docker image will be prepared and will
be given back to us so we will be able
to get this uh docker images over here
when we run that command we will be able
to find out that we got our custom
docker image also available and as you
can see that the base darker image is
also available in this one but yes we
have added up like around 10 mb of work
we have added on top of this python uh
base docker image here so that's how we
are able to do the processing over here
in this case in this setup so that's
what we uh can do to prepare a custom
environment of python with the help of
the docker file here now let's see that
we will be uh proceeding on with the
node.js to see that if the node.js kind
of setup also can be done now for
node.js again of course we got uh the uh
specific docker file which is present so
we can process that but let's create a
new folder over there so i'm going to
create for a new nodejs folder so that
we can create the work all together in
this one so i'm going to run a command
called npm init which is the comma to
initialize any empty project in case of
node now you can typically bring down
some real code also or you can say that
i want to process
an empty a project so you can give the
configurations you can give the custom
names but i want to process with these
as default name itself so ultimately
it's going to create an entries like uh
you will be able to see like all these
uh values which we are not providing
these standards value will be picked up
for the uh specific code and at the end
you will be able to get a package.json
file created over here in this one now
you can actually bring down the steps
that how you can perform or you can
build up a custom node.js based docker
image now these docker files is giving
you the capability that you can convert
a full-fledged application which is
deployable on the virtual machine you
can actually convert them in the format
of the docker containers over here in
this one so that's what we are going to
get over here with this uh particular
setup are these mechanisms
so let's go back to the document and see
that what exactly we can copy the docker
file
so we have got this docker file over
here so all we can do is that we can
copy this one so once we copy this uh
specific file here so all we can do is
that we can transfer uh these files into
the onto the server we can convert it
into the docker file there so that we
will be able to set up the
configurations and we can perform the
setup around that so docker file is
again we want to create and we want to
set up on that here so let's go back to
the server
so here we want to create a docker file
and we want to set up the files inside
that these are the different files which
is being available which is being
configured over here in this one so we
are running like node server.js which is
a master file so we are doing an expose
of 8080 then of course we have a copy
commands which is there then npm install
command is there and then package.json
file is also there now what you need to
really do is that you need to go for a
server.js file which is available in
which you can configure that how the
setup needs to be done and how the
configurations should be performed there
because that's a command that's a script
which is going to be executed within the
container so let's copy the content now
i'm going to copy this content over here
which is like a sample node.js code
which is available so i'm just copy this
one and transfer it to the server so
server.js file we have to create here
just like we did in case of the python
because this is the source we want to
transfer inside the
docker container so this is what we have
got now i'm going to uh transfer like uh
i want to change this port value from
5000 to 8080 because that's what it's
configured in the docker file of course
you can configure 5000 also depending on
your requirement you can do that
configurations
now you have got uh these two files over
here in this one so all you need to do
is that you need to run like docker
build
hyphen t nodejs hyphen app and dot so it
will automatically pick up like what
exactly it will uh you know go for the
node.js basic docker image over here so
that will be processed over here in this
one so step by step it will be able to
do the configurations
so first of all it will download the
basic docker image which is um quite uh
more incisive over here in this one once
it's downloaded onto your system then it
will proceed further with the build
activity on uh processing the docker
file performing the execution so all
that stuff will be performed with this
help of this docker build process over
here so it's going to process it one by
one in this one
and it's going to the next step where
it's transferring some of the files like
creating some working directory
transferring the files uh putting up
there and running the npm install
command
and uh then ultimately it will expose
the port and then it will have the
cmd attribute configured over there so
this is basically typically trying to
portrait it how a particular docker
image can be built up and of course once
the build is successful you can validate
it with the help of docker images here
so this is the app docker image which
has been prepared of 911 mb and uh we
have got it like a final package where
the runtime is also there and the code
base is also available now you can
pretty much
experience it like with other actual
source course like you can generate the
download some pre configured node.js
websites or the source codes here and
you can try to run them onto the docker
container so that you can get the full
uh the complete idea about that how it
goes on but right now the uh these are
the basic docker image which you can
prepare and you can build up over here
in this one so that's how it really
works on for you we're going to dig into
docker swarm so what we're going to do
in this session is we're going to go
through what a docker and docker
container is and why you'd want to use
it we'll then break out what are the
characteristics and structure of a
docker swarm environment and then
finally we'll go through and do a demo
using actual code in the command line
interface to actually run and build out
the main functions and commands that you
would use for a docker swarm environment
so with that said let's get started so
docker is a tool that we actually use to
help automate applications in our
environment so that we have a consistent
way that we're actually building and
testing and validating codes that's been
created think of it as a virtualization
but much more sophisticated and
efficient way of doing virtualization
the thing that you have that's a huge
advantage when you're working with
docker is that it's a very lightweight
software package it allows you to have
all of the tools needed for actually
running the code without having to have
the significant overhead that you would
normally have with virtualization so one
of the characteristics you have with
docker is that you can actually run
multiple docker environments in the same
host environment and for you to be able
to do this we had to figure out how this
would actually run and so to actually do
this we actually do what's called a
docker swarm and a docker swarm is an
environment where you can actually have
multiple docker images running on the
same host operating system so you can
have running in each of those docker
containers different solutions so let's
dig into what a docker swarm is so a
docker swarm is essentially a tool that
allows you to very easily create and
schedule multiple docker nodes so really
two or more docker nodes and you can
have quite a large number of docker
nodes in a single swarm uh each node
itself is actually a docker daemon and
that demon is able to interact with the
docker api and have all the benefits of
being a full docker environment one of
the other advantages you have is that
the each dot container within the swarm
can then be deployed and managed but as
a node in that entire clustered
environment so what we have here is a
breakdown of the five key elements
within a docker environment you have the
docker container you have the daemon the
docker images and the docker client and
docker registry so the docker demon
itself is what does all the work
interacting with the actual host
operating system to be able to manage
the docker containers so if we look here
here we have set up an environment where
we have three docket containers being
run with docker and what we want to be
able to do is be able to interact with
the environment because what would
happen if we actually have something
change in our environment so we have the
environment set up as a docker swarm and
one of our containers fails what we're
able to do is use the swarm to be able
to correct that failure so the docker
swarm manager is able to come in and
reschedule containers and as you would
imagine the actual swarm note has full
backups and full redundancy for any kind
of failures that would happen and we
would do all of this work through
command line interface so let's go
through some of the features that you
have within the actual docker swarm
itself so a key feature for docker swarm
is that it is fully decentralized which
means that it makes it very easy for
teams to be able to access and manage
the environment as you would expect as
well is that the communication that
happens between the manager and client
nodes within the swarm is highly secure
and of course this is really just a
fundamental that you should have for any
kind of solution but it is good to know
that docker swarm has that built in
there is also auto load balancing within
your environment you can actually script
that into how you write out and
structure your swarm environment and
that load balancing then also allows you
to then convert that swarm environment
into a highly scalable infrastructure
and then rollback task allows you to be
able to roll back environments to
previous safe environments so say
something that does get pushed out and
something breaks you're able to
immediately roll back into a safe
environment so each of the containers
are pushed out and and are controlled
using services and they actually happen
to be breast services which make it very
easy for you to be able to integrate
within your environment
and each of the different services
contains a group of containers of the
same image now by having this structure
it allows you to be able to scale your
application appropriate to the demands
on your service so if you have a service
that needs to have a significantly
larger number of services for it to run
you can actually scale that
appropriately and they can be either geo
or demand based one of the requirements
for setting up a docker swarm is you
must have at least one node deployed so
the way that the architecture is set up
is that you have a manager node and a
client node and there must be one of
each for the entire environment to be
able to work effectively so you know
here we are just jumping ahead of sales
a little bit we have two types of nodes
in the docker swarm we have the manager
node and we have the worker node which
is the client that does the actual
execution of the tasks the manager node
very similar to other systems that we've
talked about on simplylearn allows you
to actually control and manage the
actual tasks that are being executed by
the worker nodes and the working nodes
as you can imagine and then actually
execute the instructions that the
manager are sending out to it so here we
have a situation where we can illustrate
what would happen with a manager node
sending out commands to different worker
nodes the manager is fully aware of the
status of the entire swarm environment
at all times this is because of the
two-way secure communication that's
going from the manager to the worker
environment the workers as you'd expect
are accepting tasks that are being sent
from the manager so the manager sends
out a task saying that you need to be
running as a my sql environment then the
worker node will then convert to my
sequel environment and all of these
environments are scripted and controlled
by you as the manager the actual worker
nodes themselves actually have a client
agent and that client will then
communicate all different states of the
infrastructure back to the manager so
that any time the manager node is in
full control of the entire swarm the
manager is the controller of this
environment and so you always want to be
able to ensure that the manager has full
access to all the work that's happening
within the swarm and this allows you as
the manager to be able to control your
swarm and very quickly be able to react
to any changes without having to rely on
manual installations of software and
hardware and as we covered earlier on
there is a rest api that uses the
communication over http from the manager
to the worker node it's interesting to
note that it is a rest api because if
you wanted to you could actually
integrate that api into custom
applications and even then create
automated docker images to be created on
demand from third-party solutions that
you may want to create so one of the
things that's a really a big advantage
with having a swarm is that once you've
actually created the swarm any of the
services and that you create can be
accessed by any node of the same cluster
one of things you do have to do though
is you have to specify what container
image that you're going to use when
you're creating a new service and you
can do that either through a centralized
docker hub environment or through your
own private docker hub environment one
of the things that's interesting is that
you can set up commands and services to
be either global or replicated a global
service will allow you to run a service
consistently on every node within the
swarm whereas a replicated service will
only push out functionality and tasks to
specific worker nodes within a swarm so
you may be asking yourself hey isn't a
service and task the same thing no
they're kind of not in the docker world
and the difference is is a service is a
description of a task for the state
whereas the actual task is the work that
needs to get done and that's the
differentiator here so what you can do
as a docker user is you actually create
services and then you can then define
when you want them to start as tasks now
what's interesting is that when you do
assign a task to a node that same task
cannot be assigned to another node also
what's interesting is that you can
actually have multiple managers within a
docker swarm environment if you do
however go down this path you have to
elect one manager to be the primary
manager and the other managers to be
secondary managers in many ways those
secondary managers are really
similar in concept to worker nodes in
which they have the capability of a
manager but they are dependent on that
single primary manager to be able to
provide the right instructions and for
services and tasks to the entire swarm
environment so if we kind of recap some
of these we have a command line
interface which allows us to create and
connect via apis and that those apis
that we connect to in our small
environment allows us to do
orchestration via tasks and services the
task allocation allows us to allocate
work to tasks via their ip address which
allows them to execute them on the work
and then the worker nodes themselves
have to connect to the manager node to
be able to check when tasks come in so
that they are keeping a consistent
communication back and forth across the
entire swarm and then the final stage is
to actually execute the tasks that have
been assigned from the manager node to
the work node so that you have a
successful execution of the solution
you're looking to build all right so
with that said let's go ahead and we're
going to do a demo
so we're going to go ahead and do a demo
and showing how you can run docker swarm
for this you'll need to have both a
virtual environment running your manager
and your working environment so here we
have our worker and uh here we have our
manager so we're just going to open up
terminal window and we're going to go
into the manager for terminal window so
the following command here is used to
initialize docker swarm which is going
to type this in so sudo docker swarm
init
and we push the ip address for the
network we're connecting to
and open our password
and here we have now connected
and this is our manager node and what we
want to be able to highlight is the
specific token which identifies the
docker swarm environment and this is our
token right here so i'm going to copy
that
because we'll need to use that for our
worker environment so here we are in the
work environment and we'll use the token
that we just copied um as a way to be
able to connect to the manager and
connect to the docker swarm environment
and so sudo
i'll paste in the docker swamp and we'll
join that
and now here we shows that we have
joined the swarm environment as a worker
and now
we're in the manager we can actually
show that we actually have
that worker in the environment so
there's docker node ls to list out all
of the
items in that environment
sorry we actually did them in the wrong
area so we're on the right pseudo docker
node ls to list out
all the nodes in the swarm
and there you are you see we've actually
connected the
worker to the manager node and both
are active and the manager is the leader
and the worker virtualbox is in the
swarm
okay we're going to go ahead and create
a new service so docker swan create and
we're going to just change the name
to hello world for the new service and
we use the alpine image from docker.com
it takes just a moment for it to run
there we go
and there we go services converged
so what we have now is a new service
that has been created
let's go ahead and we'll list out the
services
and here we have our new hello world
service
and we go ahead and check the duck and
containers and we're going to do
docker ps and
here's our alpine it's running the
latest image
and that's the docker container id
and we can see that it was just updated
and so we're going to do is use the same
command in the worker node
and make sure everything is working over
there
go over to our worker
paste that in
so what we see here is there is no image
or container created because it's not in
the worker node it would be in the
manager node
so we can go ahead and create the new
service
and we'll make the mode global and that
way the service is available across
all of the swarm
so we're just going to execute that work
takes a moment
and
there we are
done work has been completed and we have
the two different ids which shows that
two different services are running and
if we go back to the worker mode and we
run sudo docker ps again and there we
are now we see that we have the hello
world
new virtual environment has been added
with the image of alpine and we also
have the new token id for that
if we want to kill a node from the swamp
we can use the following command which
is pseudo
[Music]
and that will force the nodes to leave
the swarm we're going to cover docker
compose so in this session what we're
going to do is we're going to go through
what docker is and then by extension
what docker compose is and how it
improves the performance of docker what
the benefits of working with docker
compose is we are going to cover as well
what the difference between docker
compose and docker swarm is because the
two products are similar but they have
two different types of job and at the
end of this presentation we'll take you
through some basic commands that allow
you to get up and running working with
docker and docker compose finally after
this presentation we'll do a brief demo
that allows you to get up and running
using some of these commands
to do your own docker compose
environment so let's get started with
docker compose so first of all we have
to kind of cover what docker is so
docker has come as an evolution of
technologies that started with virtual
machines vm machines and a vm machine
allowed you to run a complete operating
system and complete operating system and
its environment on your own computer in
your own operating system without it
interfering the problem was is that it's
very heavy and complex and in contrast
docker is a much more lightweight and
more flexible environment that you can
automate with scripts so we have to
remember that the container itself is
just software and it has dependencies
that run within that application that
are managed by docker so we have a look
at the way docker is broken out first of
all we have the docker image and we have
the docker image created by a docker
file and the docker file is a text-based
script and that text file within
dockerfile actually has all the commands
that allow you to run the appropriate
technologies within the docker image so
the docker image allows you to be able
to have a wide group of people and
consistently run the same environment
and if you want to be able to share that
docker image effectively you would do so
by uploading to docker hub and docker
hub can be available either publicly uh
through the the public docker hub
website or you can actually set up your
own private enterprise docker hub to
share your own images across your own
network and then from docker hub people
can then pull their own docker image and
build new containers that are consistent
on the original docker container that
you created so it's a great way of being
able to have your entire team scale up
easily and effectively so one of the
questions that will come up though is
what if you want to use two containers
in a single service and an example this
might be like a web server that is using
a database but the database may be in
one container and the web server may be
in another container which is very
typical for your own web and database
infrastructure so very similar um
scenario but how would you do this with
doc app so by using just docker itself
it's actually very difficult to do this
you can do it but it's just very time
consuming and just not a very good use
of your productivity but with docker
compose you can actually do the whole
process quite quickly and easily and
hence the reason why we have docker
compose to allow you to have two or more
docker containers running in the same
environment being able to communicate as
if they were running in a production
environment so let's dig into what
docker compose is so let's consider a
scenario that you'd have today so
myntra is a
fashion website similar to amazon and
you'd go to mentor with your web browser
and
on that website you would go through a
number of activities such as logging
into your account browsing a catalog
you'd have your checkout application
server and uh you go through the typical
process of building out an application
behind each of these services are
different products such as you know to
have an account database you'd have a
product database different checkout
processes and these would all be run
behind the scenes and each of these can
be considered a micro service so the
more microservices you build into your
environment the more complexity you're
adding and the more of value it would be
to have each of these services in their
own container but as a developer you
want to be able to jump from one
container to another container so your
login account can then be passed on to
your product catalog and then be able to
move through the whole process so the
environment that you would see today
would be small like what we're showing
right now where you'd have your server
and your database and you may have a
server running on apache tomcat or a sql
server you'd have different databases
and you'd want to be able to have each
of those in their own containerized
environment so the way that duck compose
runs is that it works as a single
service so you have the docker compose
running multiple containers but the
perception is of a single service run
the thing that's great though is that
each of those containers will run in
their in isolation and but they can
interact with each other so unlike a
normal docker environment where you have
multiple docker images running
completely in isolation of each other
these are images that will run in
isolation but can interact with each
other the docker compose files are very
easy to write they're all written with a
scripting language called yaml and yaml
is an xml based language it actually
stands for yet another markup language
but it's an xml based language and it's
very easy to use the great thing about
learning yaml is that a lot of open
source tools in the devops environment
use yaml as the scripting lane and then
finally in docket compose as a user you
can actually go and and trigger all your
services within the containers to start
with a single command as you can imagine
this dramatically reduces the amount of
work that you as a developer have to do
so let's take an example of if you're
running a container one with a ninjx
server and one with the redis database
uh you can create a yaml docker compose
file that actually has the instructions
on the containers needed to build out
both environments and then you can run
each of those environments separately
but have them connected as a single
service so the benefits of duck and
compose is that you have a single host
deployment environment you can run this
all on one piece of hardware you can
have a quick and easy configuration
using yaml scripts the productivity that
you get as a developer significantly
increases because you're not having to
have time wasted trying to configure
just traditional docker containers by
themselves you now have a way of being
able to interact with those containers
and then finally security is at the
center of all of these containers so
each of those containers are completely
isolated from each other and they are
controlled with the same level security
that you'd have with a traditional
docker image but there is a question
here around docket compose isn't it
similar in concept to docker swarm
because at a high level it kind of seems
like both do the same thing and the
answer is well actually no they're
different there are similarities but
there are also differences and
particularly for a developer these
differences will really start coming out
in scale as you start working on your
solutions so let's look at docker
compose so docker compose will allow you
to create multiple containers on a
single host and that's the important
part having a single host which is maybe
your development pc with docker swarm it
also allows you to create multiple
containers however you have to manage
those multiple containers on multiple
hosts which makes a lot of sense if you
are running an operations environment
but not so much if you're doing a
development environment and docker
compose is scripted with yaml which is
very easy for you to be able to control
your scripts docker swamp doesn't have a
scripting technology like yammer so it's
a little bit harder to work with so what
we have here is just some basic commands
that allow you to get up and started
working with docker compose and in our
next demo we're actually going to take
you through how to use all of those
commands so we're going to go ahead and
do a demo on how to use docker compose
um the first thing you want to do is
check that you have docker installed so
what we're going to do is we're going to
open up the command window and we're
going to type in docker you'll be able
to see now that we have docker installed
if you don't have dock installed go
ahead and install docker you can go to
google search to install docker and
they'll give you the instructions for
that we also have videos that we've
already done if once you have docker
installed then you want to do a google
search on docker compose or go to the
docker.com website and search for the
compose section and look for the install
docker compose instructions so we
already have another tab which has
the instructions already installed
you'll see on the left hand side there
are a number of docker tools you want to
expand the docker compose section select
install compose and then on the right
hand side you'll have different install
options for mac windows and linux if
you're installing on those platforms
make sure you copying the correct
command line so there's a couple of
command lines you want to
copy copy the first one over and we
paste that in and it's going to go ahead
and download all of the files for
compose it takes a while but uh we have
to get another file so while it's
downloading we'll go get the other
command line just go back and grab it
real quick it was a little faster but
we'll copy that over there was a second
command instruction and post that
command yep there's the command right
there and that will apply the
appropriate binary and once you've done
that you can actually go ahead and
validate that you have the correct
version of docker compose installed and
for that you want to write the command
docker dash compose space dash dash
version and that will then give you a
version build once you know that you
have a version built that means that you
have everything installed correctly on
your machine so you can see here that we
have a version number which means we
have everything installed you might see
a different version number depending on
how old the video is when you're
watching it but we're using variable uh
content at the moment let's go ahead and
clear the screen and now what we're
going to do
is create a folder where we're actually
going to install the ammo file that will
have the instructions for our docker
components environment so we're moving
the cursor to the desktop and on the
desktop we're going to create a new
folder and using the mkdirf command and
we'll call this one docker compose f for
file and then we'll move the cursor into
that new folder by using cd command and
now we are in the folder called docker
compose f and you can go look at your
desktop and you'll see it's there and
now you want to select um pound touch
docker dash compose dot yml and that
will actually create the new yaml file
for you and you can use the ls list
command ls docker compose.yaml and
they'll allow you actually now to step
in and edit that file so let's go ahead
and hit return and that will allow us to
go in and edit the file so now i'm in
the editor and i'm going to write some
instructions um so i'm i'm going to put
a couple mistakes in these instructions
so we can see how dr pose catches those
mistakes
so but most this is going to be fairly
correct so you can just type this out so
we're going to start with surfaces colon
and we'll do web colon and then we
create image colon and we'll do nitrix
and then we'll do a database colon and
we call the image redis and so what you
can see because we have two reference
images we're actually calling two
different images two different
containers that will be created by
docker hub uh so what we're gonna do is
uh where we can actually show you um how
that's pulling in you can go to docker
hub and you can actually see the
references to the images that we've just
created so go to dockerhub which is
hubhab.docker.com
and you'll see that uh nigix
redis those are the default names for
the images so you could do
other images like http for apache web
server if you wanted to there are a lot
of images in docker hub so suddenly have
a lot of fun building uh tools from that
environment so we're going to save those
files um in the docker image we're just
going to do colon wq to exit this screen
i save the text
let's go and run our yaml file and
you'll see the two different error
messages that will come up so we can do
cat docker dash compose dot yml and here
we have a display of the text that we
just wrote and now let's go check the
validity of the file that we just
corrected so we'll do docker dash
compose config and we should get an
error message and there we are error
message and the reason why we have an
error message is because the spacing is
not correct in the yaml file itself so
let's go to the actual yaml file we
created let's go through and we're going
to use uh just the file finder and
you'll just open up the yaml file in
your text editor your favorite text
editor and here we have um the code that
created it and that's use the correct
spacing so that everything is spaced out
appropriately in the image and so this
is the spacing that you'd expect to see
a space a line between surfaces and the
first image and the first image is a tab
in and then it referenced what the image
is and let's go ahead and clear the
screen and we'll see whether or not
we've got that all correct it click um
this clear screen and we're going to
check that everything is running
correctly and we're seeing we're still
getting an error message and the reason
why we're getting another error is that
there's still a config error in this the
actual yammer file so one of the things
you have to do when you're creating a
yaml file for docker composers you
actually have to have the appropriate
version
number in there so what we have to do is
we have to go and find which is the
appropriate version and there are three
major versions one two and three
depending on the age of docker that you
have installed on your computer uh so if
you have the very latest version of
docker 18 and newer you would put 3.7 as
the version number and what we're going
to do is we're going to just check on
the version that we have installed and
so just clear the screen and then we'll
just do docker version and what we have
is our version of docker's
17.12 now this is the version of docker
not docker compose uh it's your main
docker environment and so if we go back
to our web browser we'll actually see
that version 17 should align with
version number 3.5 yep there we are
version 3.5 so what we want to do is go
back into our yaml file and the very
first line that we want to put in above
the services is the version number and
that version number we're going to put
in is 3.5 so we type in version version
and we put colon and then version number
is in brighton quotes and you save that
and now what we can actually do is we
can actually go ahead and use the
single line instruction to run both of
these uh
two images that we've created because
everything is configured correctly or
just one note you'll see that the
version number is actually at the bottom
of the list and that's just the way that
docker compose works it pulls out the
services and the images that you'd
create and then put the image the
version number at the bottom of the list
so in the presentation we talked about
how you can use one line to trigger two
or more images and so to do that we're
going to do sudo docker dash compose up
dash d and it's going to create the two
environments we have the web environment
and the database environment and let's
use pseudo docker ps to actually list
out that all the processes that are
running right now and there we are we
actually see all of the images that are
running we have the names the commands
the images and everything's up and
running and if we want to close both of
those images we can actually use a
single line of command as well and that
command will be sudo docker dash compose
down and that closes both of the images
and we can see that all the databases
and the web services images have been
closed and sudo ps which it lists that
there is nothing running and that's how
to use docker compose in this one we are
going to talk about that what exactly is
in docker uh why the docker networking
is important uh what is the docker
networking all about features of docker
networking container network modes uh
network drivers and then we will be
having a demo on creating a bridge
connector a bridge network and we'll see
that how we can run our custom docker
container on that custom docker network
so let's go ahead with this activity
what is the docker all about so docker
is an os level virtualization software
platform which helps the user to develop
deploy and manage and run applications
inside a docker container now the best
part about this is that not only you
store the source code you also put up
the dependencies inside it so if i have
a job-based application so apart from
the java code base i will also be
putting up the dependencies like jdk and
also inside the docker container so it's
a complete package which you're going to
prepare and inside this package you will
be having all the dependencies and
whatever the binaries you require you
will be having it inside a docker
container now if you see the diagram
over here you have a infrastructure on
top of which you have the host operating
system
then on top of the host operating system
you have the docker engine now docker
engine is the main component here which
takes up all the requests which make
sure that all the containers are up and
running and it actually gives an
interface or kind of a runtime to the
docker containers so that they can run
their specific applications so this is a
basic component basic architecture of
the docker now docker container is a
very lightweight software package okay
usually inside these docker containers
you will be having all the dependencies
all the software packages everything is
included in this site these docker
containers so it's a complete package if
i'm looking forward for a jenkins
application container in there
everything will be there right from the
base operating system to the jdk and
then on top of that the jenkins
application running there so the moment
i go there and run the docker container
of jenkins i will be able to have a
full-fledged jenkins application
available which i can access through the
url and through a specific port 8080 so
docker container is a kind of a package
where both the dependencies and the
source code and the libraries are
available why exactly the docker
networking is important let's talk about
some scenario over here so my
application is something which totally
works perfectly fine into my system and
there is no issues on there i ran it
perfectly fine and i got it as far as
i'm able to interact everything i'm able
to do but the same application does not
works on the other person's system now
what could be the issue because it's
working on one machine and it's not
working on another machine now the
application does not work on another
system because there is a difference in
the computer systems maybe one system is
having a different machine and another
system is having a different machine and
you may be having some of the
differences maybe in the uh term of
hardware maybe in the terms of software
so the differences are possible in two
different machines so how we can get a
solution that we don't get this kind of
problems and once the container is
prepared it should be able to run it
across different systems so docker
networking is the ideal solution for
this uh problem over here with docker
networking the application works totally
fine and
it's something which can work on any
system you don't have any dependency
that it will run only on a specific
machine or a particular system so what
exactly is in docker networking all
about so docker networking enables a
user to link a docker container to as
many as networks you know he or she
requires
so you can actually connect a docker
container to a specific network the
docker networks are used to provide
complete isolation to the docker
containers so you can have it like okay
i want to run some couple of containers
in a different network and another
containers i want to run it into a
different networks so you can do that
isolations and the whole purpose of
doing that isolation is so that we will
be able to have a proper networking and
proper executions and all that stuff so
docker networking is a very important
concept when we talk about or when we
come up with the interaction on having
the docker containers isolated so it
resolves most of the problems okay so um
you can have like a multiple containers
in running in same network you can have
a different uh particular networks also
there so a specific network
have its own attributes and then you can
use those attributes to connect to that
containers and to access that containers
but the whole idea is that the
containers are something which is
specifically running in a set of
servers or in a set of uh platform so
whenever i'm trying to look forward to
that particular container
it has to be there into a network if you
don't run it into your custom network
then whatever the default network
present it will be hosted in that
network there so how does the docker
networking actually works so you got a
decker file so using the dockerfile you
got up a custom docker image and from
this docker image you have to actually
go there and uh you know put up like the
docker container so um you can also
store this docker image to the docker
hub so that the same docker image can be
shared across different users and they
can also pull down their docker image
and they can have the container running
in their systems so for the
collaborating the docker image you
require the docker hub and the container
is the ultimate thing or object which we
need to create out of the docker image
when we go with the uh particular
process when the whole process goes on
over there so what happens that uh the
instead of the docker hub you can use
your own private repositories also
that's something which totally relies on
to you that how exactly those things
works on so a dockerfile creates a
docker image using the build command
a docker image contains all the project
source code all the dependencies uh
using this docker image you can actually
run the source code in order to get a
docker container the moment you
initialize or running stance of docker
image you will be able to get a docker
container you can actually use the
docker hub for collaborating or for
sharing the docker image so you can
store the docker image on docker hub and
then different people can actually go
ahead and download or pull this docker
image onto their system and they can
also run their specific containers so
what are the different advantages we get
with the docker networking very first
one is the rapid deployment portability
better efficiency of faster
configuration scalability and the
security over here so these are some of
the advantages which we get when we talk
about the docker networking here now
let's talk about the container network
model here so what is the network model
we are looking forward from the
containers perspective now this is a
kind of architecture here now in this
one let's see that how it actually works
on now you have a docker engine which is
a main component which takes up all the
things and all the important components
are actually interrelated with each
other now the network sandbox is the one
in which you will be having your
container running up and running now
every network is having its own
attributes the uh particular different
gateway ips the ip addresses the range
of ipads the cidr blocks also everything
can be different to for two different
networks so the whole point is that you
will be defining okay if you don't
define that i want to run this uh
particular container into a specific
network then definitely that's going to
run into default network which is which
gets created the moment you do the
installation of dockers but anyhow any
network is required for running a docker
container so there are different network
drivers which is available there so if
you feel that you want to create a
network so you have to choose a
particular networking or the
connectivity over there and uh it really
helps us to understand how the
configurations and how the different
modifications and those changes can be
really done here so a lot of changes are
actually going on and you know
performing there and this really helps
us to understand that how the things are
being done as such over there so network
is something which is very important
from the containers perspective so the
network sandbox isn't kind of a isolated
sandbox that holds the all the network
configurations of the containers so you
will be requiring a at least one docker
container network if you want to run a
container inside in that particular
sandbox so sandbox is created when a
user requests to generate an endpoint on
the network so that's where the sandbox
gets created uh it can have severals and
points in a network as it represents a
container's network configurations like
ip address mac address dns name so every
container will be having its own unique
ip address right so that can be a
particular endpoint to connect to that
container and it can have it like
different uh endpoints and different
different networks so that's always the
possibilities which is available there
now the endpoints uh establishes the
connectivity for the container services
with other services also so the moment
you work on the uh
particulars uh end points so that can be
used for having okay there is a service
running in a container so how you can do
that so if you in order to connect that
you require these endpoints so that you
can establish the connectivity with the
container services whatever running
inside these docker containers
right now the network is something which
provides the specific underlining
network attributes like the networking
support to the docker containers because
these uh network sandbox
boxes will definitely have a requirement
of the network so how you're going to
get that that you will be only able to
get when you go okay i will be looking
forward for the connectivity and i can
go for the communications and i can give
the hardware because although it's a os
level virtualization but still you
require some interaction with the
hardware from the networking perspective
and then docker engine is a the base
engine which is installed on the host
machine and it's actually the main
component which make sure that the
docker containers and the corresponding
docker services are always up and
running and the uh using the network
drivers you can actually create multiple
networks onto your system and you can
have those uh configurations
now the network architecture is
something which helps us to provide the
connectivity among the endpoints that
probably belongs to the same network and
uh it's something which is a kind of
isolated network so different different
networks can be isolated uh networks and
we can have the endpoints to them so
there are different ways in which we can
establish the connectivity and this is a
complete network architecture which is
there so you have a network drivers you
have the networks you have the network
sandboxes in which internally the docker
containers are running and then these
network sandboxes are having their
respective endpoints there to access
them to establish the connectivity now
let's talk about the network drivers now
there are five type of network drivers
which is available first one is the
bridge
host none overlay and mac we land so
these are the different uh particular
network drivers which is available over
here uh first one is a bridge it's a
private default network created on the
host if you go there if you go to the
installation of a docker this is the
default driver which gets installed onto
the system onto the host the containers
linked to this network will have an
internal ip address through which we
they can actually communicate with each
other on the same machine also you can
establish the connectivity you can
connect to the containers using that
private ip address but outside the
server you will not be able to have the
communication but internally you can
connect to the containers and containers
can also interact with each other they
can also communicate with each other
with this one uh the docker daemon
creates the uh docker zero so if you run
the ipconfig config or if config on the
system you will be able to see a docker
0 kind of ethernet bridge network which
is created using which you can see that
okay this is the network which is
created by default it's a default
installation or default configuration
which automatically happens the moment
you set up a docker instance so you
don't have to go into the configurations
or in the setup of there it will be
already available on that particular
installation board there and next one is
the host one so it's a public network so
when we go with the public network it's
actually uses the host iprs and uh tcp
port in order to
interact with the service running inside
the docker container so if you are
looking forward that i want to reach out
or i want to connect to the container
but i want to use an
ip address which can be accessible from
outside world probably some other server
should be able to resolve that in that
situation the host network driver comes
into the picture so it effectively
disables the network isolation between
the docker host and the docker
containers which means that using this
driver a user can actually run multiple
containers you know it's it's not
possible for the user to run multiple
containers on the same host because of
the fact that you are using
the host ip address now when we were
talking about the bridge connection at
that moment of time we were getting the
private ip addresses which was totally
isolated and totally unique so there
were actually if you create a using the
bridge connection multiple containers so
you will see that if there are five
three containers everyone will be having
a different private ip address but the
moment you go for the host one so in
that situation the ipad is not going to
change so you get some restrictions okay
because the combination is of ipads and
port so iprs and 8080 can happen only
once it cannot happen multiple times so
that's the limitation that you cannot
run multiple containers on the same host
due to this restriction and the next one
is the none so in this network driver
the docker containers will neither have
any access to the external network or it
will not be able to communicate with the
other containers also total isolation
and total private containers are being
done when we use this driver so if you
these options are usually used when you
want to
disable so this is not doing nothing but
disabling the total networking of
functionality for a specific container
that's what it's happening over here
next one is the overlay so this one is
utilized for creating an internal
private network to the docker nodes in
the docker swamp cluster so overlay does
not comes up in case of a standalone
docker installation the moment you go
with the particular docker swamp cluster
at that moment of time the overlay type
of network is created so docker uh swam
is an acquisition tool so
that requires a overlay kind of uh
driver which can uh you know help them
to achieve the networking in case of
cluster because in case of docker spam
you have a master node manager node
worker nodes different different
machines are there so in that situation
overlay is the
main component or is the main type of
driver which is used and then we have
the mac vlan so it simplifies the
communication processes between the
containers
this network assigns a mac address to
the docker containers with this mac
address the docker you know servers will
route the network traffic to a router so
it's it's not on the basis of ip address
it's actually on the basis of mac
address so
on the specific mac address the network
this docker server will redirect the
network to a specific router
right it's usable when a user wants to
directly connect the containers to the
physical network rather than the docker
host so that's where this communication
works on so it's a direct connectivity
between the host network and the docker
container so there is no virtualization
which is happening over here so uh it's
something which is you know giving a
direct access to the networks but it's
definitely on the basis of mac address
which on which the communication is
happening now let's talk about the
networking implementation and we'll see
that how we can go for a particular
bridge network implementation there so
let's go back to the virtual machine so
i am connected to a particular system
here so i can check that if the docker
is available to me and i can just run
the docker version so it says that okay
the client and the server component both
is available there now we are going to
see that what are the different uh
containers which is what are the
different docker containers network
which is available there so i'm going to
run a command called docker network ls
now the moment you do it over here you
will see that none host and bridge these
are the different containers uh network
which is available there and you can see
their network ids the names the drivers
but drivers is also very important
because that's what we are going to use
here so it's a very good one here so the
default one you can see that the bridge
is available and uh it's a default one
whenever you create any container by
default whether you give the container
attribute or not it's something which
gets created into the uh terms or in the
basis of the container only in the
default network only so how we can get
that we can always get that part by uh
you know having the understanding that
what network we are using so i'm going
to run a couple of containers a small
container and we can see that how
exactly uh the containers can be
executed and uh can be done over there
right so let's see so i'm going to run a
command
docker
run hyphen d id
iphone iphone name
alpine one
alpine
image is what i am going to use
and usage
so it pulls down the alpine image that's
what it happened and the same thing i'm
going to run but this time i'm going to
run
alpine 2 because
i want to create two containers
right so with this one what will happen
that i will be having uh like two
containers available here so i can say
like darker ps so i can see that two
containers that are in ink one is the
alpine and one is alpine two right so
now what happens that we will see that
how the connectivity happens and uh what
are the network details so what i'm
going to do is that first of all i'm
going to do an uh inspect over there
onto the
uh bridge connectivity so that i can get
the detailed information so um this is
the name of
the particular ones of the network so
this is the network which is available
and this is the default one so if i
scroll up you can see that this is the
name of the bridge connectivity and even
if you run the docker network list so uh
you will be able to see that the id also
so id also if you compare so uh e65
that's the one which is available now
this one is something which is using a
driver called bridge and here you can
see the subnet information now if you
scroll down you can see that two
containers are available here so i did
not provide any kind of network details
but uh definitely what happens that the
two containers which i deployed are
basically running inside this network
okay and you can see that uh the bridge
name docker zero is the internet or
network which gets created uh which
during the installation of docker gets
configured now
you can see that uh this is the ip
interest this is the ip address here
this is the mac address and this is also
a mac address here so uh the ip address
you can see this is a
3.0.3 in the last and this is dot 2 over
here so you can see that the increase
the sequence is there so alpine one was
having an ip dot
172.17.0.2 and uh alpine 2 is having an
incremented ips like a different one as
in three so you can see that these
different ip addresses are there and uh
represents if you want to access them if
you want to connect on them you will be
able to have the connectivity
accordingly so even if you go inside
these containers you can actually see
that what exactly uh the connectivity
you want to establish or the
connectivity you want to perform here
right so this is the way that how the
network usually works and uh the
networks which you are using over here
is the bridge once which definitely
helps us to understand that how the
configurations can be done
now so uh what we are going to do over
here is that we will try to see that how
exactly uh we can
uh go ahead and uh we can connect on
there and we can also see that if we are
able to communicate with each other
because probably uh if i run like ping
command over here
and i'll put the containers like two
and i'm able to reach out there is no
problem in reaching out to these ips
because these are the private ip
addresses and i will be able to reach
out to them without any problem and
without any concerns so from the current
uh connectivity perspective there is no
problem as such and i have a connection
available over here but let's see uh
we'll go uh back to the containers we'll
see that how exactly we can talk about
we can reach out to the one container
with each other so i want to connect
alpine one with and find two so how we
can do that
so i'm going to use like docker
fine one
okay now i got a terminal so what i can
do is that i can go for the ipa in this
show
so with this one what will happen that i
will be able to know the ipad is so dot
to is the one which is available over
here okay so this is the ip address now
i can simply do the uh small pink
command so i can say like ping
google.com so that will show me that if
i have an internet connectivity so that
is great so i got a connectivity with
the internet uh over there so i will be
able to reach out any websites or any
kind of that order now uh i have another
ip so dot three is remember we were
using three front ip so i can actually
do a ping also here so ping hyphen c
five
five request will put and uh three will
do here now we are trying to reach out
to the alpine two over there so although
we are connecting to the alpine one but
we have the connectivity with alpine two
also so from alpine one you can connect
to the alpine two containers so that
shows that since both of them are
running in the same container so they
are having the automatic uh connectivity
and you can easily reach out to them and
without any issues you can do that and
similarly the same thing you can do it
uh in case of uh
alpine two also so you get it connected
to the alpine two and uh you can uh just
follow the same thing so you can connect
it uh with the if you go to the alpine
two you can connect to the alpine one
also so if you come out the containers i
will be always up and running and uh you
will be able to have the uh mechanisms
there so the whole idea about these
things is that it will be basically
helping you to understand that how the
executions can be done and how we can
perform the activities as such over here
so this is the way that how we deal with
the networking and how the containers
gets created into a network and then
they can interact with each other
did you know the famous global
researcher gartner predicts by 2023 more
than 50 percent of the companies will be
adopting docker containers
however a serverless container like
docker will have a rise in the revenue
from a small base of
465.8 million in the year 2020 to
944 million in the year 2024. in this
video we will be doing a side-by-side
comparison of the docker containers and
the virtual machines but before that
let's have a look at the objectives of
this lesson in this session you will
have a good understanding of what a
virtual machine is and what a docker is
followed by that we will have a major
difference between
docker and the virtual machines
also we will discuss some of the key
differences between docker and virtual
machines and finally a use case on what
made bbc to use docker
so the first one
what exactly is a virtual machine it is
an isolated computing environment that
enables a person to use an operating
system via a physical machine virtual
machines provide the functionality of a
physical computer as you can see on my
screen there is a virtual machine and
this is how a typical virtual machine
looks like now let's look at what a
docker is
docker is an operating system level
virtualization software platform that
enables software developers and it
administrators to create deploy and run
applications in a docker container with
all their dependencies
and a docker container is a lightweight
software package that includes all the
dependencies like frameworks libraries
and many more which are essentially
required to execute an application
this is the architecture of docker tool
now let's move on to our next main topic
for the discussion that is
docker versus virtual machine
when it comes to comparing the two we
could say the docker containers have
much more potential than virtual
machines
as you can see on the left and right
hand side
both the images look similar now let's
define the layers of virtual machine
from the bottom up let's begin with the
infrastructure
infrastructure could be a computer
system a laptop or a virtual private
server such as an amazon ec2 instance or
as your virtual machine or gcp virtual
machine instance
on the top of the infrastructure runs
the operating system an operating system
is a software that manages hardware and
software resources for the computer
programs
on your laptop this will be likely
windows mac os or linux flavored
operating system such as ubuntu next
comes the hypervisor a hypervisor is a
firmware that builds and runs virtual
machines there are two types of
hypervisors
type 1 hypervisors are hyperkit for mac
os hyper-v for windows and kvm for linux
operating systems and type 2 hypervisors
are virtualbox and vmware then we have
the guest operating systems consider an
example where you want to run two apps
on your server in total isolation
this process would require two guest
operating systems which will be
controlled by a hypervisor
virtual machines come with many
dependencies where each guest operating
system will at least occupy 512 mb of
your ram
this is worse because each guest
operating system needs its own cpu and
memory resources eventually this will be
expensive
then on top of that each guest operating
system
requires its own dependencies such as
binaries and libraries since every
application has different dependencies
it requires its own set of libraries
finally it's the application this layer
consists of the source code for the
application you have built
this was all about the virtual machine
on a server here's what the same setup
looks like when you're using docker
containers
here you'll notice that there are a lot
fewer layers docker doesn't require a
bunch of massive guest operating systems
let me break it down from the bottom up
again
infrastructure and host operating
systems are the same as we discussed for
the virtual machine coming into the
third layer instead of a hypervisor
docker uses docker engine
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
next we have our dependencies
just like on the virtual machines here
dependencies are built into a template
called docker images as you can see on
the screen each application is still
isolated and occupies less space
now let's have a look at the significant
differences between docker and virtual
machine
let's start with the operating system
first
docker is a container based model where
containers are software packages used
for executing an application on any
operating system
on the other side virtual machine is a
container based model it utilizes user
space along with the kernel space of the
operating system a kernel space is where
the core of the operating system runs
and provides its services to the user a
user cannot modify the space and user
space is the portion of the system
memory in which the user's processes run
docker containers share operating system
kernels with other applications and
result in a higher server efficiency
hence docker provides the most
substantial default isolation
capabilities among the other
configuration tools
on the other hand virtual machines do
not share the operating system also it
does not provide isolation in the host
kernel
in docker
multiple workloads can run on a single
operating system but in virtual machine
each workload needs a complete operating
system or a hypervisor
the next significant difference between
the two is the performance in the case
of docker they use the same operating
system without any additional software
like hypervisor
in case of virtual machines performance
issues are a major problem it can be due
to the several reasons like cpe
constraints memory allocation network
latency and many more
running multiple virtual machines lead
to an unstable performance
docker containers can start up quickly
and result in less boot up time whereas
virtual machines do not start quickly
and lead to a poor performance now let's
talk about the next difference which is
portability with docker containers a
developer can build an application and
store it into a docker image later he or
she can run it across any host
environment
but when it comes to virtual machines it
has portability issues virtual machines
do not have a central hub like docker
dust and it requires more memory space
to store data
docker containers are smaller than
virtual machines due to which the
process of transferring files on the
host file system is easier on the other
hand dependency on the host operating
system and hardware makes virtual
machines less portable while
transferring files virtual machines
should have a copy of the operating
system and its dependencies due to which
image size is increased and becomes a
tedious process to share data
the boot of time between the both is
very different the application in docker
containers start without any delay since
the operating system is already up and
running on the other hand virtual
machines take much longer time than it
takes for a container to run
applications these containers were
basically designed to save time in the
deployment process of an application
whereas in virtual machines to deploy a
single application virtual machine needs
to start an entire operating system
which would result in a full board
process
so those were the major differences
between docker and a virtual machine now
let's discuss the minor differences
between them
docker is not always in a running state
it stops when the stop command is
executed whereas the virtual machines
are always running in the background
which will result in huge ram
consumption talking about snapshots
docker has a lot of snapshots a snapshot
is an image that you can upload on a
private repository to access it on
another host but virtual machines do not
consist of any snapshots in docker
images can be version controlled just
like git they have local registry called
docker hub where users store and
distribute container images on the other
hand virtual machine does not have a
central hub they are not version
controlled
docker can run multiple containers on a
system
users can connect multiple containers
using user-defined networks and shared
volumes multiple containers can be
accessed on the same machine and share
the operating system kernel with other
containers each container is isolated in
user space also docker containers occupy
less space than virtual machines and
start instantly
virtual machine can run only a limited
number of virtual machines on a system
since each virtual machine requires a
certain amount of cpu ram memory and
other resources your physical systems
will have less space
multiple containers can be started at a
time on the docker engine the isolation
environment allows a user to run and
deploy several containers simultaneously
on a given host
virtual machines can run only a limited
number of virtual machines on a system
since each virtual machine requires
certain amount of cpu ram memory and
other resources your physical systems
will have less space now that i have
told you the differences between docker
containers and virtual machines let me
show you a real life case study of how
pcc uses docker
bcc news is a british news channel over
500 developers working across the globe
pcc news delivers broadcasts in almost
30 different languages and with over 80
000 daily news in english alone the news
channel ran more than 26 000 jobs with
more than 10 continuous integrations
with sequential scheduling the company
had issues with identifying a way to
unify the coding process and monitor the
continuous integration consistently also
the existing jobs took up to more time
that is up to 60 minutes to schedule and
perform its task
docker allowed bcc news to eliminate job
wait times and run jobs in parallel it
also gave the users the ability to work
in a more flexible ci environment where
entire core processes were unified and
stored in a single place however docker
succeeded in spreading up the whole
continuous integration process in this
topic we are going to talk about what
exactly is the various docker commands
which we can use to interact with the
docker docker images docker containers
and some core components of docker is
what we are going to talk about in this
particular topic here now let's begin
with what exactly is in docker because
we are trying to explore that what are
the different docker commands we can
eventually run to interact with the
docker because uh you have the command
line interface which is available there
using which you can run some couple of
docker commands and internally you know
you will be able to have some particular
processing which is done at the docker
end now docker is in configuration
management tool it's being used as a
configuration management tool just like
the other configuration management tools
in the industry in the market now it's
pretty much used by the developers to
make sure that they
wrap or they package an application with
all its dependency
now normally in a virtual machine what
we do is that we host or we install the
dependencies separately
and then on top of that we host our web
applications or whatever the application
we have we host it on that particular
framework or platform
but here in this scenario we are talking
about like how we can wrap an
application all together with its
dependencies all the dependencies are
getting wrapped are getting uh packaged
up into a single entity
and you know that's what we call it as a
docker container so docker is in
configuration management tool and the
containerization tool which is there
which helps us to wrap or package both
the dependencies and the source code
within a single unit called docker
container and this is the docker
container which the developers use to do
the deployment across multiple
environments
so um as part of the process um when you
are working on the uh hosting of your
application onto your docker so
ultimately you are looking forward for
an entity called docker container so if
you see if you go through the diagram
over here so in this one
this is in kind of a basic way uh
architecture that how the docker is
being a architect and is getting
deployed
so initially you have an infrastructure
like a physical infrastructure is there
you have the uh particular course memory
infrastructure all those things are
available there now on top of this
infrastructure you are hosting up a host
operating system
this host operating system is
responsible for taking up all the
requests and interacting uh providing a
particular interface between the uh
particular docker and the infrastructure
the core hardware so it acts like a
medium over here
so after the host on operating system on
top of that you are going to install the
docker engine docker software it's just
like you got a virtual machine on linux
and on top of that you are installing
the docker software
once the docker engine is installed then
docker engine will take care of
management of the docker containers you
don't really have to do a lot of work
docker engine is going to take all the
internal work uh the communication
between the operating system and the
infrastructure so that needs to be done
by the docker engine so docker engine
make sure that the different container
gets uh up and running and you can see
that in this scenario in this diagram we
have container one container two and
container three and all these containers
are actually having its own applications
and the dependencies bind it up together
so that's the reason why we are saying
that with the docker we are getting a
complete package end-to-end package has
been given to us in which we have both
the uh particular source code and the
binaries and the executables embedded
inside that so it's a complete package
which uh is getting created in the form
of docker container and the developer is
responsible for preparing this docker
container so that these containers can
be deployed on the docker host and you
can get your application up and running
so this is what we have docker into our
particular and the architecture of the
docker here now let's see that what are
the different commands we have for the
docker here now the very first one is
that what are the different images
related to commands which is available
there the very first one is the
command which we typically use to
prepare a custom docker image now i can
easily go to the docker hub and i can
pull down a docker image which is
available there but let's assume that
you are working on application source
code so you want to prepare a docker
container for that now that docker
container you will not be able to have
it on the docker hub you have to prepare
on your own
right so in order to prepare your own
docker image all you have to do is that
you have to run docker build command now
in this case we have to prepare a docker
file which will act like a docker a kind
of a docker build script just like in
case of maven we have found xml file and
in case of and we have built.xml file so
here we have the dockerfile which is
available there and this dockerfile make
sure that whatever the steps are
mentioned in this dockerfile in the
build script it's going to perform a
series of steps and the build will be
done so docker build is the command
hyphen t is the tag that what exactly
name uh
you know whatever the image you are
building so what exactly tag name you're
trying to provide over here so here we
are using a tag name called my image and
then after the column we are providing
that what version we want to go here 1.0
2.0 5.0 so whatever the version you feel
that you want to uh you know refer you
can do that
now this is the exact way that how in
the actual world the darker images are
getting built up by the uh respective
windows let's say that jenkins is born
and jenkins wants to prepare a docker
image so they will be preparing the
docker file in the same manner and
prepare these docker images and publish
it to the docker hub so all the docker
images are built up the custom docker
images are built up with the help of
docker files so docker build is the
command which will process the docker
file and give you a particular docker
image in the end
now how to list down all the docker
images so docker list uh ls is something
which is there so this will eventually
help you to list down all the docker
images which is listed on or which is
available into your system so that will
be listed out over there for you
if you feel that you want to remove a
particular image in that case you can go
for docker image rm command and uh
whatever the image you want to remove
you can give the respective image name
and the tag name there so docker image
rm command is there using which you can
actually see that how the image can be
deleted from the host over here in this
one right so whatever the ways whatever
the you know mechanism is there so we
are making sure that how the image can
be built up and how we can go for the uh
built up and a particular image can be
deployed over here in this case so in
order to delete it in docker image so
you can go for docker image rm command
to remove a docker image completely from
the docker host
so these are some couple of commands
which is available there using which you
can actually interact or manage the
docker image because in order to prepare
or in order to run a docker container we
require a source and that source we are
going to get it from the docker image so
now we are going to see that how we can
execute these commands so first of all
what we need to do is that we need to
see that how docker build works for that
we require a docker file so i am going
to have a simple docker file over here
in which we are going to have a basic uh
docker image selected as an ubuntu after
that we are going to go for the one
attribute where we are going to do the
installation of a specific
package like let's say git and
accordingly you can whatever software
you want to prepare you want to set up
you can do that and put up the commands
over here in this docker file so i'm
going to save this file and after that
what i need to do is that i need to run
like darker images to find out that how
many images are there there is no images
present so i'm going to build a docker
image over here with the name of
simplyland or whatever the
name you want to give you can
give it over here in this case it's not
any kind of restricted word so you can
give the actual docker image name also
that what for what purpose you're
preparing this image and with that what
will happen that it will take up the uh
values whatever attributes you have put
up into the docker file so that will be
processed and that will be picked up and
once that uh docker file has been
processed has been uh you know prepared
you will be able to see that yes a final
product or a final docker image is
finalized and prepared over here in this
one so we just have to wait for the
whole process to complete and once my
docker image is prepared i will be able
to have a particular setup done or
achieved over here so that's what we
require over here in this one to be
performed
now once the installation is done so you
will be able to see like the final
docker image is being prepared over here
so it says successfully built which
means that uh the docker image is
prepared now if you run like docker
images you will be able to find out that
this image is available over here in
this one now you are seeing like two
images because one is like the basic
image which is being pulled down because
we are using a docker file to do that to
process that one there
now in case you want to remove it so all
you need to do is that you need to run
like docker
image
rm and simply learn
so if you do that what will happen that
your docker image which is related to
simply learn will be wiped off from your
system and in case you want to do like
removal of the ubuntu also so that also
you can do over here with the help of
docker images
and that will be removed from your
system so your docker images will be
removed from your system
using the uh particular command called
docker um image and then rm command to
remove the docker image from your system
from your host here so that's how you
deal with the different docker images uh
commands over here in this one now let's
go back to the document now the next
section over here is the docker
container commands over here so all the
commands related to docker containers is
what we are going to talk about over
here now the very first one is the uh
particular container so in order to
create a container so you can run the
command called docker create and the
image because for a container you
require a docker image that's a pre
request so once the docker image is
prepared you can just simply run docker
create command and that will help you to
create a container onto your system now
if you want to run a particular
you want to create a container and you
want to run it also at the same time so
in that situation you can go for a
docker run command the main difference
between the docker create and docker run
command is that the docker run command
is going to uh run a container and uh
it's going to give you a response from
the command but
the docker create command is going to
create only the container so once the
container is up and running so that's
only being done by the docker create
command but the docker run command is
going to actually do the
uh preparation of the container also and
at the same time you are being given as
in particular
response also like you know what a
command you want to run so that response
also you will be able to get here and if
you feel that you want to rename an
existing container so for that you can
go for the docker rename command so
existing container you can rename it
with the new container and that's how
the particular rename of an existing
container will be done with on to the
docker host here so docker rename is the
command using which you can rename an
existing container and you can get a new
container over here in this case
so these are some of the options some of
the ways that how you can interact with
the containers how you can manage them
onto your docker host over here so you
can run it you can create it and you can
rename the containers also so now what
we're going to do is that we're going to
see that how we can work on this
particular container commands here so
first of all i'm going to quickly pull
down jenkins image so that i can create
a tab container out of that so it's in
kind of a 600 around mv docker image
which is available there now you can
also have a custom docker image prepared
using the docker file or you can have a
ready-made docker image pull down from
the docker hub also so this is going to
pull the latest version of the jenkins
from the docker hub so that we will be
able to proceed further on that and we
will be able to continue with the
hosting so we will be converting or
running this uh specific docker images
in the form of docker containers so that
we will be able to have uh instance of
docker container over here running in
this one so that's what we are trying to
do here
so we will just wait for this pull
activity to complete because it's in a
heavy docker image so it may take some
time to download and once it's download
you will be able to see that docker
images is showing a specific docker
image of jenkins here now you're going
to create a container out of that so
you're going to run a command called
docker create and jenkins over here
so that will help us to do uh the
creation of a docker container and once
that is done so you will be able to see
like using docker ps command that if any
container is up and running and if you
go for docker ps hyphen a you will be
able to see that yes a particular docker
container is in
created mode now this is not in running
mode because you see that when i ran the
docker ps command it was not showing it
in the running mode because i just
created a docker container here and the
created status also shows that yes the
docker container is created but it did
not run over here
so if
you want to run it so definitely you can
say like docker start
and
[Music]
you can give the container name and that
will help me to
start my container over here but of
course you if you feel that you want to
directly create a container and uh you
know you don't want to create the
container only you want to start it also
so in that case you can go for the
docker run command so docker run command
is something which can be used instead
of uh doing the execution so you can say
like docker
run
jenkins
and what it will do it will definitely
help you to get the
container created onto of the jenkins
over here in this case it's not like
only creating a container but in fact
it's actually starting the container
also so you can see that it started over
here into your screen itself that whole
jenkins gets initialized over here in
this one so this is the way that how
you can initialize or you can create a
container now i can just do a control c
over here because it says that and
jenkins is up and running so you can
start using this one according to your
requirement over here right so i'm just
doing ctrl c so that it can be stopped
over there
right now
so this is the way that how uh typically
we can create the containers now we got
like two containers over here and one is
up and running and one is something
which i just closed just now over here
now if you feel that you want to rename
a container let's say like this is a
container which is available but it's
not having a meaningful name now i want
to convert into a meaningful name like
dev underscore jenkins so that you can
easily do with the help of docker rename
command because that will rename the
docker container name so that you will
be able to connect on to that and you
can go for the processing so that's what
we can get over here in this one so this
is how you can do the
various management of the resources over
here so let's go back to the main
content
now if you feel that you want to remove
all these top containers because what
happens that sometimes we simply stop
the container but we do not remove it
from the
docker hose because um we are not going
for the cleanup now clean cleanup is
very required because these containers
are actually taking up the disk space
also so we need to make sure that we
should be using we should be having like
minimum amount of disk space utilization
so for that what we need really need to
do is that we need to run docker
container prune command so this will
basically help you to prune or do the
cleanup uh purge of all the containers
which is running on the host machine
here
and that will definitely help us to
remove all the containers which is in
stop stator so that will be simply
removed over here in this one so this
really completely removes all the
stopped containers onto the docker host
over here in this scenario now second
one is that it creates a new image from
a containers file changes now the
way what happens that normally what we
follow is that we use the docker build
command to do the build process right so
docker build command is being used in
that particular way now if you really
want to go for a preparation of a new
you know image so all you need to do is
that you need to create a new image from
a container file
so you can run the command called docker
container commit command and you know
whatever container is there so that will
be saved or preserved as a docker image
because sometimes we also do some ad hoc
changes or modifications on the fly
inside the docker container by going
inside the docker container and doing
the steps so we really need to preserve
those steps and that is the reason why
we are converting a docker container
in the form of a docker image here so
that's what we are trying to perform
here so docker container is something
which is uh being uh done over here in
such a way that whatever the steps
whatever the changes we are trying to do
so that needs to be performed over here
in this case so docker container uh
commit command is being used so that we
can get a particular you know final
image as part of the container so the
container will be converted in the form
of a docker image over here and the last
one is that how we can remove an
existing container so we can go for the
docker rm command which is available
there using which you will be able to go
ahead and you can get a particular
container removed from your existing
system so docker arm command is pretty
much there using which we can see that
how we can remove an existing container
from your system as such
what exactly now we are going to see
that how we can perform the various
commands
on the containers here
so the very first command which we want
to do here is that uh you know in order
to see that how we can actually remove
all these top containers but for this
one what we really need to do is that we
need to first of all run some couple of
containers so i'm going to quickly run a
container called docker
or run hyphen d httpd
so i'm going to run a particular web
server over here and
it should be able to give me a proper
container up and running so i can just
double check or value that it has with
the help of the
docker ps command
so docker ps command should give me the
proper confirmation that whether the
container is in up and running over here
or not so you can see that it's up
entering from last 11 seconds here now
we got a command where you know for
example we have got some stopped
containers but again you have to
manually remove them one by one now if
you don't want to do that stuff if you
feel that whatever the stock containers
which is available that should be
automatically removed from your system
then we have one command called docker
container prong now for this what we
really need to do is that we need to
actually stop this container because
again it will be only picked up like
whatever the containers which is
available in these top setters only
those will be picked up
so i have copied the container name here
in this case and i need to stop it so
that i will be able to
remove it with the prone command over
here in this one and then i can run like
docker
container print command which will
basically remove all the containers
which is in these top status and once
that is done you will be able to see
like that is something which is
completely gone from your system so this
is a way that how it can not only take
care of these top containers but it's
actually being done so that you can
remove the multiple containers with the
single command itself over here so this
is not something which will be
executed one by one on a different
container but yes it will definitely
take care of doing the uh changes and
performing the activities
now another thing is that how we can
actually do the
commit of a particular docker image
let's say that we got a docker container
which is uh running and there are some
changes like some dynamic changes which
is available there so you want to save
this uh
particular container as a docker image
so that whatever the changes temporary
changes are there so that will be also
saved as a docker image so all you can
do is that let's say that again
run a particular container
of http here so this will help me to get
a particular container from the http
perspective available of to us so docker
ps command will give me the option
now here i have got a container in which
it's running now if i want to save this
container let's say that i went inside
it did some modification did some
temporary changes i want to refer it i
want to use it so how you can do that so
for that what you really need to do is
you need to run like
docker commit that's a command or you
can say docker
because you're going to do a docker
container commit over here so the
comment of the container is what we are
going to do so docker container commit
and then we are going to see like what
is the container so for container we
will be
yes again copying
that particular container id and we'll
say like custom
image colon version one so we will be
giving a custom name or a name of a
docker image and a tag over here in this
one so this will basically save my
docker container which is available in
this one in the format of a particular
docker image in a format of a docker
image over here in this case so as you
can see that almost both of them are
having the same change but
the container which we got uh over here
in this one so this whatever the changes
uh you want to wish you want to do you
can do that and you can then put it up
into the uh form of a docker image a
final docker image and it lasts if you
want to remove it so docker rm and
container id now this again docker arm
will come remove only those containers
which is in stop status so if you want
to forcefully
remove it so you will be able to use it
with the help of hyphen f which is the
force will remove which will remove the
container completely from your system
and once it's removed from your system
you will be able to see like there is no
container running up and running over
here in this one so docker ps hyphen a
is not something which is up and running
over here in this one so they completely
completely got uh wiped out from your
system so that's how you basically work
on these commands on this uh particular
uh container related commands here so
let's go back to the main content
right so these are the commands where we
can actually do the management like how
to stop the containers how to remove the
containers and how to get a new you know
darker image out of the container here
now let's see that how we can list down
all the running containers if you feel
that you want to list down all the
running containers then you can go for
the docker containers ls command and
that will eventually help you to list
down all the containers which is
available there which is uh being there
into your system
then docker stop command is there to
stop a container
so whatever container which is there in
the running status so that will be
stored with the help of the docker stop
command and then the restart command is
there using which you can do a restart
of a container into your system
right so once the container is restart
so whatever the application running
inside the container so that will also
be restarted over here in this one so
these are the different options which is
available using which we can explore
over here in this one somewhat more
commands about the container so again i
am going to run a container over here of
http here so that i can show you some
couple of more commands over here now we
can run like docker ps or you can say
like docker container less will which
list down on all the containers which is
available to you which is being
you know present in this case now if you
want to do any kind of operations like
let's say if i want to stop it
now the moment you do the stop over here
so you will be able to uh stop the
container which is up and running for
you and
you can come uh you know whatever the
application is being deployed that will
also not be available to you because
that's simply uh completely gone for you
now you can see that the docker
container list is not able to show you
that particular option that whether it's
being shown or not because it's in stop
status so in fact you can do a you know
start or you can do a restart so both
the operations you can pretty much do
over here so that you will be able to
have a complete activity implemented so
restart is also something which is
available which can definitely help you
to see that how the things really work
and how you can go for the container uh
you know the management over here in
this case so you can do a container
container ls command to list down what
are the containers which is available
then you can do a restart you can do a
stop also infect start is also there
which can help you to see that how the
containers is are really available so
this is the way that how you can manage
like you know even the restarts and all
because this really helps you to even do
the restart of bounces to the
application which is present inside this
container so that also you will be able
to see with this particular component
here
so that let's go back to the main
content
and then um you know killing a running
container so if you really want to kill
a container so for that we can go for
the docker kill because rocket stop is
also going to stop the container but if
you want to forcefully kill it so in
that case you can go for the docker kill
command to do that particular
kill on the containers and then if you
really want to go inside the container
and you want to attach your terminal so
for that you can go for the docker
attach command and with this what will
happen that you can go inside the
container you can do whatever the
changes you want to perform you can do
that and you can again come back outside
that also so normally typically we use
it so that we can see some errors of
in the logs which is coming up in the
containers and if any kind of issues are
coming up for the applications we should
be able to know that part
now the last one is the uh particular
weight docker weight is there so that
will block a container and uh it will go
in the wait status so docker weight and
the container id or the container name
you can give so with that the particular
container will go into the block status
let's see somewhat more commands over
here so we can run like docker container
ls again to find out like what container
is available so you can see that this
particular container is available over
here in this one now if you see like if
i want to get uh attached to this
container if i want to attach my input
and output stream with this container so
you can run like docker
attach and the container id so your
terminal will be stuck over here because
it's taking up whatever the progress
which is going to be done in the
container that will be in you know a
kind of attached to your terminal over
here and you will be getting the output
but the moment you come out of this like
you say control c so you will see that
you know it's basically sending the
request to the container that is getting
stopped so you will be able to see like
the docker container list it's not going
to show you because the container is in
stop status so again you have to do the
restart of the container to make sure
that the container is up and running
right so the attach one will help you to
go uh and attach your standard input and
output with your container with a
running container but when the moment
you comes out you will be able to
disconnect or shut down the container
and again i had to restart that
container over here in this one then
again of course we have like docker
weight
then container is there so this will
basically put the uh container into a
block status because all the requests
and all will be not sent to the
container and it will be blocked and
if you really want to like
consume or if you want to make use of
the container you will not be able to do
that so docker weight command will us
kind of block the container and you know
if you again uh try to come out of that
so
again the request to the container will
be uh
resumed and they will be able to use on
that part so docker read command is
being used to block the container and
then we have docker attached to attach
to the container the standard input and
output and lastly is the docker kill
which is going to kill the container and
you will be able to
see that the container is in simply
killed stator so it's
you know it's not like a stopped over
here if it's gracefully stopped then the
exit code definitely will be zero but in
this case since it's being killed the
particular status is 137 over here in
this one so that's a non-zero status
code so that's how we you will be able
to manage the containers on different
aspects let's go back to the main
container so these were some of the
commands which was there from the docker
containers perspective let's talk about
some of the commands from the share
command perspective so how we can share
the docker images
so we have a typical pull push mechanism
which is there using which we can
actually interact with the docker hub or
a docker registry so uh if you really
want to pull a docker image so in that
case you can go for the docker pull
command
if you want to push an image to the
registry so you can use for the docker
push command if you want to execute a
command inside a particular running
container or you want to
execute a command or a script or
something like that so you can go for
the docker is a command and with that
the execution will be done and you will
be able to get a response so that will
make sure that yes whatever the
execution you are trying to do so that
will be done over here in this mechanism
now let's see that how we can do a pull
and push activity to a docker image so
first of all the pull command is pretty
simple all you need to do is that you
need to say that okay i want to pull a
docker image uh if let's say that our
docker image is already present then
it's just going to say that it's already
up to date it's already available there
but if in some cases you feel that the
docker image is not available and you
want to pull it so all you can do is
that you can give that a docker image
name and that you can give the tag also
but in this case we are using the tag as
in latest
so that's the reason why even if you
provide or you don't provide it doesn't
really matter so i'm going to give like
a docker pull a mysql over here and the
moment i hit on this one what will
happen that it says this a particular
docker image is not available into my
system it's going to download it and
once it's going to be downloaded you
will be able to see that into your local
system so docker images is something
which is going to help you with the
commands and it will give you the
particular ways that how the docker
image is available so i can run like
docker images over here to see that what
are the different docker images which is
available in this manner
now if you really want to move any of
the docker image then of course you have
to do a docker login
and uh you will be doing the
uh you know the connectivity to the
docker hub and then establish the
connectivity and all so what you need to
do is that you can run the docker login
command we will also see this command in
the next particular slide but right now
we are just doing it because we want to
showcase that how the push really works
so uh you can actually give your
username that uh what username you are
holding up
so the password does not shows any
activity but yes still it will let you
know that whether the login is
successful or not so in this case it
says login is successful so all you need
to do is let's say like i got this
custom image and i want to push it to
the docker home so
you need to rename or you need to do a
tag over here because the same if you
run
docker push
custom
image colon version one so if you do
that it will not be pushed into these uh
particular docker hub so it's going to
throw e error over here that the access
is denied so all you need to do is that
you need to do a tag
here so you have to rename it in such a
way that you should be able to
use uh add your username over there
because dockerhub will identify that if
it's there with your username then only
it will be pushed otherwise it will be
simply rejected over there so that's
what you need to do you need to rename
your docker image uh the same docker
image which you have you have to append
your username of the docker hub and once
that is done so all you need to do is
that you need to just run like docker
then push is there
then this image name and then version
one
so the moment you do this what will
happen that it will start transferring
those darker image to the docker hub you
see this uh specifies that yes this is
going to the docker hub docker dot io
where my username is there and this is
the custom image which is available
there so if i refresh my page on the
docker hub i will be able to see like
this public repo which is available
there but again this one just requires a
credentials and the login which we did
in just a last command where we ran the
docker login command to do the login to
the portal and after that only we are
able to do the setup and the
modifications over here so that's how
you do the login and you are able to
connect on that now these are some of
the pull and push operations but let's
say that if you got a container which is
up and running like this is uh
right now we are not getting any
container which is available over here
so you can say like docker run
hyphen d httpd like i'm just running a
dummy container over here so that i will
be able to
show you this command now if you for
some reason want to go inside the
container and want to see some
processing and want to see some content
so you can run the command called docker
azik
iphone id and there you can give the
container id this is nothing but the
full format of the container id which is
given to you so you can use this one
also or you can use the shortened also
shortened value also you can use and in
the last we can say like bash
the moment you do this you will be going
you will be going inside the container
you see that this is the hostname which
is being shown as the container id you
can do a like psiphon ef command and it
will
throw an error that the ps command is
not available because you are running
this command into the docker into the
docker container so using these kind of
commands which is not available in
container will help you to identify that
yes you are not on the host machine you
are in fact into the docker container so
that's the reason why you can do it
because for you the parts and all
everything is same the terminal is also
same so you may not be able to
differentiate in that part so that's the
reason why it's preferred that we use
that uh commands which is going to fail
but that's okay it will give you that
okay this command is failing because i'm
into the docker container right now so
that's what we are performing over here
right and you can come out of that but
still the docker container is going to
be still up and running over here in
this case so the container is not going
to
be down over here in this one so that's
how we manage the container we can go
inside and we can check some
informations and get some files there
so these are some of the commands where
we can interact now in order to log into
the docker hub because before doing the
docker push you have to log in you have
to get a credentials and the
connectivity with docker hub so you can
run the docker login command where you
can see that how the execution can be
done now using the docker login command
you can interact with the particular
docker hub you can set up the
credentials once the credentials is
being set up so what you can do is that
you can go ahead and say that okay the
uh configurations is done and uh we can
go ahead and we can perform the
execution so docker login is a command
where you can give the credentials
docker info is the command using which
you can get the uh information about the
docker tool so whatever the docker info
is available there so those things you
can actually get it over here in the
case of the docker info so docker info
is going to give you complete
information that what exactly you have
the information available over here on
this one
and then we have the docker history so
using the docker history you can see
history of the docker image that what
exactly uh the mechanisms or what are
the different image ids are available
there so this is basically giving you
the complete history on how the
docker image is prepared all the
commands is available there and that
will help you to eventually go and
understand that how the images can be
going on and you can manage on that part
so these are some of the couple of
options which is available there where
we can see that how the executions can
be done and we can go ahead on that
particular part so docker history is the
command again which will help you to see
that how
you can go for the uh particular
mechanism and you can listen on on the
things over there so docker login was
already done previously when we tried to
push the image but again if you try to
run docker login you will be able to do
that now docker info is something which
will give some additional information
about the docker and all the
informations about the docker will be
given back to you over here in this one
so the complete clarity
uh then let's say that you got a docker
image called
httpd now you want to check the history
of this image that how this image is
prepared what are the different layers
which is available how many layers are
there how much size is being modified in
each and every layer so you can see that
we got a layer where we have a
particular changes of 7.838 mb but
pretty much the uh company from the
complete size of this httpd the major
portion is actually of the uh this one
the basic operating system which is
being implemented and then of course
there are some packages which got
deployed due to which this uh 60 mb and
7mp size is coming up there so this
actually gives you the complete layer
wise mechanism that what are the
informations which is available and how
the modifications actually got modified
and got changed over here in this one so
this is the additional uh help which you
can get from the docker to
manage the containers here
so these are the ways where you can
interact with the docker hub if you
really want to create a volumes for the
container so you can go for the docker
volume create command so docker volume
create command is there using which you
can create the docker volumes and you
can pretty much do that uh setup so
docker volume create is the command
which is available there for that
particular part it will create a volume
for you now let's see that how we can
actually work with the volume so you can
run the command called docker volume ls
to find out what are the different
volumes which is available there now if
you really want to create a volume over
here in this one so you can say like
docker volume create and you can go for
the
volume name here
now the moment you do that what will
happen that a volume will be created and
you can validate it with the help of
docker volume ls command that whether
the volume is being created or not over
here so this is the way that how you can
manage the volumes onto the docker host
now let's talk about some of the docker
swamp commands here now docker spam
commands is there to set up a particular
mechanism where you can see that how you
can perform a setup you can actually go
ahead and see that how the setup and
modifications can be done
so docker swamp is there where we can
see that how the execution needs to be
done so
you can go for the command called docker
spam init command this will actually go
for an initialization of our docker
swamp cluster and once the docker spam
cluster is initialized then you can
pretty much go there and perform
whatever the executions you want to
perform you can do that and you can
execute as such over there so docker
swap init is a command using which you
can actually see that how the execution
needs to be done
and how we can perform the uh you know
mechanism and the changes over here so
docker sam init hyphen fn advice uh adr
address is there which helps you to see
that how the executions can be done
now joins you have the docker swamp join
command which is available there
now if you go for docker swam join
command so
you can have a particular host so
dockers swam join command is there which
you can run on the node machine and in
that case what will happen that node
will be a part of the docker spam
cluster
and then if you want to leave uh from
the swamp cluster then you can go for
docker swam leave command and it will be
simply removed from the docker swamp
cluster there some of the couple of
commands which using which we can
initialize or we can
remove from the docker spam cluster here
so docker
spam is already being initialized or
it's been created when the moment you do
the installation of docker so docker
swam in it is the command using which
you can in a lash uh analyzer docker
container now once you analyze over here
so initial after the initialization you
got a command you which you want to add
it like you want to run it onto the
docker spam uh cluster
it will act like a worker node so that
you will be able to deploy the
containers on top of that
also if you want to join it as a manager
so you can also get the join token again
so it will give you the proper command
now if you run like docker
node ls so you will be able to see like
what are the different nodes which is
available there and for any reason if
you're not comfortable with that and you
want to re-initialize your docker spam
cluster so all you can do is that you
can say like docker
swam
leave iphone f and you will be left out
of the docker spam and now if you want
to run like knock docker node ls you
will not be able to get that output
because it's saying that there is no uh
particular swap manager which is
available so you can run docker spam in
it or you can run the join command to
connect to that specific node but we
have already left it and nothing is
available over here so that's a way that
how you can manage like what are the
different docker spam commands we can
typically run to manage the docker spam
cluster now let's talk about the docker
compose commands now docker compose
commands is actually they are using
which we can create multiple containers
it's not only one container which can we
can create we can create go for multiple
creations of the containers with the
help of docker compose file so docker
compose hyphen version is the u command
which we can give you the version of
docker compose which is being used so
here we use a particular vml format file
which will help us to create the
multiple containers we defined the
services that what are the different
containers we want to create here and
then with the help of a docker hyphen
compose dot ml file we can create or we
can have that particular docker compose
file setup over here in this case so
docker hyphen compose.vml file is used
to do the setup and the modification so
that you will be able to have the
modifications done and you will be able
to find out a particular uh multiple
containers gets created all together so
docker compose is there is the way that
how you can do the setup how you are
going to run the docker compose file so
in that case you're going to run the
docker hyphen compose up command which
will help you to set up like how the
compose can be done and once you are
done with the docker hyphen compose up
command so using this the compose will
be done and the containers will be up
and running so these are the commands
using which we can manage multiple
containers using the docker compose one
so let's try to run some commands
related to docker compose so docker
iphone compose iphone version will let
you know that what exactly version of
docker compose is installed into your
system so you can run typical app
command to do the installation so docker
hyphen composes the package name which
you can install so that the executables
and the package can be installed into
your system onto the server now all we
need to do is that we need to create a
docker compose file so what we need to
do is that we need to create a docker
hyphen compose dot yml file is the
default name of the vml file which we
want to create here that's a standard
name so once you create this all you
need to do is like you need to put some
values attributes the very first one is
the version value that what version of
uh this particular attribute you want to
create here let's say that i want to
create a version too so i will configure
here that yes the version 2 is what i
require i want to set up over here in
this one
now again if i want to configure that
what are the different services we want
to run because services is the main
thing which we will be running on this
machine on the server here so that's
what we require so then we need to put
for a particular service called web so
web service we want to search and we
want to run and then again we need to
take care about the spacing because
that's a very important part
and we need to provide the values of the
image
and
all these configurations here so that
you should be able to set up like how
the uh images and how the docker images
can be built up over here so uh web is
the service which you want to deploy and
then of course the image is the
attribute which is there for the web
that yes engine is the one which we are
trying to build up now you can give the
ports configuration also so you can say
like ports
and inside that you can say like what
port mapping you want to perform so you
can say like
um 8080 so sorry 80
is what you can dash for the engine x
because it runs on 80 port but now i
have to run like 80 port i want to
attach that port over here in this one
so i can specify that 80 port should be
available in this one so i'm going to
save this one here and i'm going to run
a command called docker iphone compose
up now this will run the containers in
the interactive mode but if you feel
that i want to run in the detach mode so
you can say like hyphen d also which
will of course run these ones into the
detach mode and it will be executed so
it will process your docker compose file
and since you have used a standard name
called hyphen docker hyphen compose dot
ml so it will automatically pick that
docker or details and start creating the
container docker is a popular devops
tool used to automate the deployment of
applications in lightweight containers
so that applications can work
efficiently in different environments
docker was initially released in 2013
and since then has become the go-to
solution for containerization
in this video we have compiled the most
important docker interview questions
that you might face in a docker or
devops interview
so without further ado let's get started
so let's go through and you're going to
be asked to explain what the
architecture of docker is and docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so docker
uses a client server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line and and then the
docker daemon which is run as a rest api
and within the command line will accept
the requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact um you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a docker
or docker-like environment and really
the the arguments for docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all docker does contain and occupy
docket containers occupy significantly
less space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
docker is significantly faster than a vm
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single docker image docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation docker data volumes can
be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your arguments for docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is leverage the power of
docker swarm so docker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the docker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed
so what are the commands to create a
docker swarm and so here we have an
example of what a manager node would
look like and once you've created a
swarm on your manager node you can now
add worker nodes to that swarm and again
when you're stepping through this
process be very precise in the execution
part that needs to be taken to be able
to effectively create a swarm so start
with the manager node and then you
create a worker node and then finally
when a node is initialized as a manager
node it can immediately create a token
and that token is used for the worker
nodes and associating the ip address
with the worker nodes question 17 how to
run multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers a single service by using
docker compose and docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the composed files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yamos
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a docker file so
docker file actually is used for
creating docker images using the build
command so let's go through and show on
the screen what that would look like and
this would be an opportunity where if
you're actually in a technical interview
you could potentially even ask hey can i
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things i really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as an architect this
should be something that you are
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and suddenly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a docker file so we go through
and that we have a docker file that
actually then goes ahead and creates the
docker image which then in turns creates
the docker container and then we are
able to push that out up to a docker hub
and then share that docker hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between docker image
and docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a docker
container an image is built using a
docker file and it stores that docker
file in a docker repository or a docker
hub
and you can use docker hub as an example
and the image layer is a read only file
system the docker container is a
collection of the runtime instances of a
docker image and the containers are
created using docker images and they are
stored in the docker daemon and every
container is a layer is a read write
file system so you can't replace the
information you can only append to it
so while you can actually use yaml or
our writing you're so a question you're
going to be asked is instead of yammer
what can be an alternate file to build
docker compose so yaml is the one that
is the default but you can also use
jason so if you are comfortable working
with jason and my that is something that
you should be uh get comfortable with is
you want to be able to use that to name
your files and as a frame reference json
is a logical way of being able to do
value paired matching using a javascript
like syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a mysql docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a docker image or pull
from an existing docker image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want to be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has my
sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image and below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the commands
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have a docker
registry is an open source server-side
service used for hosting and
distributing docket images whereas in
contrast for repository it's a
collection of multiple versions of a
docker image in a registry a user can
distinguish between docker images with
their tag names and then finally on the
registry docker also has its own default
retreat called docker hub for the
repository it is a collection of
multiple versions of docker images it is
stored in a docker registry and it has
two types of public and private registry
so you can actually create your own
enterprise registry so you're gonna be
asked you know what are the cloud
platforms that support docker really you
know lists them all and we have listed
here amazon web services microsoft azure
google cloud rackspace but you could add
in their ibm bluemix you could put in
red hat really any of the cloud service
providers out there today do support
docker it's just become an industry
standard so what is the purpose of
expose and publish commands in docker so
if we go through expose is an
instruction used in docker file whereas
publish is used in docker run command
for expose it is used to expose ports
within a docker network whereas with
publishers can be used outside of a
docker environment for expose it is a
documenting instruction used at the time
of building an image and running a
container whereas with published is used
as to map a host port to a running
container port for expose is the command
used in docker whereas for publish we
use the command-p for when we're doing
our command line used in docker and
examples of these are expose 8080 or
with docker we would put in or for
publish we'd do the example docker run d
dash p and then
0.0.0.80 a colon 80 as our command line
in this video we're going to cover a
common conversation which is kubernetes
versus daca so let's go through a couple
of scenarios let's do one for kubernetes
and then one for docker and we can
actually go through and understand what
the problem specific companies have
actually had and how they're able to use
the two different tools to solve them so
our first one is with bose and bose
had a
large catalog of products that kept
growing and their infrastructure had to
change so the way that they looked at
that was actually establishing two
primary goals to be able to allow their
product groups to be able to easier more
easily catch up to the scale of their
business so after going through
a number of solutions they ended up
coming up with a solution of having
kubernetes running their iot platform as
a service inside of amazon's aws cloud
service and what you'll see with both
these products they're very cloud
friendly but here we have bose and
kubernetes working together with aws to
be able to scale up and meet the demands
of their product catalog and so the
result is that we're able to increase
the number of non-production deployments
significantly by taking the number of
services from being large bulky surfaces
down to small micro services being able
to handle as many as 1250
plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of time and value has
been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at daca
and see what a similar problem that
people would have so uh the problem is
with paypal and paypal and processes
something in the region of over 200
payments per second across all of their
products and paypal doesn't just have
paypal they have braintree and venmo so
the challenge
that
paypal was
really being given is that they had
different architectures which resulted
in different maintenance cycles and
different deployment times and an
overall complexity from having a
decades-old architecture with paypal
through to a modern architecture with
venmo through the use of docker paper
was able to unify the application
delivery and be able to centralize the
management of all of the containers with
one existing group the net net result is
that paypal was able to migrate over 700
applications into docker enterprise
which consists of over 200 000
containers this ultimately opened up a
increase in availability for being able
to
add in additional time for building
testing and deploying of applications
just a huge win for paypal now let's dig
into kubernetes and docker and so
kubernetes is an open source uh platform
and it's designed for being able to
maintain a large number of containers
and what you're going to find is that
your argument for kubernetes versus
docker isn't a real argument it's
kubernetes
and docker working together so
kubernetes is able to manage the
infrastructure of a containerized
environment and docker is the number one
container management solution and so
with docker you're able to automate the
deployment of your applications being
able to keep them in a very lightweight
environment and being able to
create a nice consistent experience so
that your developers are working in the
same containers that are then also
pushed out to production so with docker
you're able to manage multiple
containers running on the same hardware
much more efficiently than you are with
a
vm environment the productivity around
docker is extremely high you're able to
keep your applications very isolated the
configuration for docker is really quick
and easy you can be up and running in
minutes with docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside of your
devops environment so we look at the
deployment between the two
and the differences kubernetes is really
designed for a combination of pods and
services in its deployment whereas with
docker it's around about deploying
services in containers uh so the the
difference and here is that kubernetes
is going to manage the entire
environment and then and that
environment consisting of pods and
inside of a pod you're going to have all
of your containers that you're working
on and those containers that can control
the services that actually power the
applications that are being deployed
kubernetes is by default an auto scaling
solution has it turned on and is always
available whereas a docker does not and
that's not surprising because docker is
a tool for building out solutions
whereas kubernetes is about managing
your infrastructure kubernetes is going
to
run health checks on the liveness and
readiness of your entire environment so
not just one container but tens of
thousands of containers whereas docker
is going to limit the health check to
the services that it's managing within
its own containers now i'm not going to
kid you kubernetes is quite hard to set
up it's it's if of the tools that you're
going to be using in your devops
environment it's it's not an easy setup
for you to use um and for
this reason you want to really take
advantage of the services within azure
and other similar cloud environments
where they actually will do the setup
for you docker in contrast is really
easy to set up you can as i mentioned
earlier you can be up and running in a
few minutes as you would expect the
fault tolerance within kubernetes is
very high and this is by design because
the architecture of kubernetes is built
on the same architecture that google
uses for managing its entire cloud
infrastructure in contrast docker has
lower fault tolerance but that's because
it's just managing the the services
within its own containers what you'll
find is that most public cloud providers
will provide support for both kubernetes
and docker here we've highlighted
microsoft azure because they were very
quick uh to jump on and support
kubernetes uh but the reality is is that
today google amazon and many other
providers are having first level support
for kubernetes has just become extremely
popular in a very very short time frame
the company's using both kubernetes and
docker is fast and every single day
there are more and more companies using
it and you should be able to look and
see whether or not you can add your own
company to this list and with that we
have come to an end of this video on
docker fill course i hope it was
informative and exciting if you have any
questions about the topics covered in
this video please ask away in the
comment section below our team will be
happy to solve all your queries thank
you for watching stay safe and keep
learning
you